Four,
three,
two,
one.
Robin Black Gentlemen.
What's up buddy?
Hey man,
it's great to see you.
Are you fresh back from Singapore?
I am,
yeah.
I was in Singapore like 48 hours ago.
Did they make that special shiny silver
one for you?
Because that looks like this design for
you know,
it's,
I mean,
yeah,
it does Kinda look like it's designed
for me,
which is why I wanted it,
you know,
it's a rock and roll.
One Championship afc championship.
So what's it like over there man?
So let me explain to everybody.
One FC is like the Asian version of the
UFC is a gigantic organization that has
been going on for how long now?
Two thousand 11.
So solid seven years and really high
level fights over there.
Amazing,
amazing fight.
Singapore itself is wild.
So I went over there to chat with them.
So chapter three,
a city of tongue runs it and he and I
had been chatting and I love kind of how
they see martial arts.
So they don't call it even fc anymore.
It's just one championship.
They don't even use the word fighting.
Really it's martial arts.
And the way I see it and the way I
studied martial arts and share it is an
art form like painting or yoga or you
know,
things,
things of that nature,
less spectacle.
That's always how I've seen it.
Oh,
is how I love it.
And that's how they see it and that's
how they present it.
And that's,
it's presented from this sort of
inspirational own your history kind of
way in Asia.
And that was what attracted me to them
right away.
I mean it's,
it's definitely an art form.
It's values based,
like they're kind of seeking to inspire
people through these athletes and
artists.
It's pretty fucking cool.
Really what's motivating them to take
this sort of radical approach.
So it's wild that you say that because
to me this is the approach.
So I think what we do,
or the way that we presented in North
America is radical.
I think martial arts is an art form.
Martial arts is this inspiring thing.
I mean,
you take,
say for example,
on loud song,
he is there 185 pound and 205 pound
champion.
He's from me and Mar.
They have never had a world champion in
any sport ever in their history.
I don'T think they've had a gold
medalist in the olympics.
They've never had that.
This guy's a two division champion that
will and when I talked to [inaudible]
about it and he was talking sort of
about why he sees it this way and why
he's proud to present it this way.
He's like,
he knows without question that there are
kids and he won his 205 pound title in
me and mark in a stadium in me and mark
and he said he knows without question
there's a kid in,
they're going to become a lawyer one day
because of that and they can feel it and
it's real.
It's not like.
It's not like a marketing strategy like
this is how they see martial arts and
it's how martial arts is viewed in asia.
Martial arts.
I get to travel so much now it's view
different in Russia.
It's view different in Brazil also
viewed in Russia.
Russia is wild,
man.
I've got to work for a acb,
you know,
acb,
some other organization,
big organizations.
So in Russia it's very masculine and
it's about about victory and about
showing your power and your strength and
it really.
And,
and Russia is like that,
you know,
it's a reflection kind of of Russia.
Yeah.
I'm the martial art thing.
I absolutely agree with you on that.
It is an art form,
but I also think it's a fight like
gilbert melendez versus diego sanchez.
Yep.
That's an art form,
but it's a fight that was,
that was a fucking wild fight and
there's no way.
That's just art.
That's an art and a fight.
It's both things.
Is that a fight is art.
It is in a way.
It's an expression of your personality,
your individuality.
It's heart,
your fearlessness.
A hundred percent,
but it's a fight.
I'm not scared of the word fight.
No,
I'm not.
I like it.
I liked that word,
like it's.
But it is an art form.
Yes.
Fights are art.
Yes,
definitely.
I mean like anderson silva's second
fight with shale son,
the way he landed that need of the body
on the ground,
but that is just art.
That's art,
you know?
I mean if you go back to leo machida
just landing that front kick on vitor
belfort,
that's art is.
It's especially for someone who
practices.
Yeah,
martial arts,
you see the beauty in that.
You're like,
ah,
it's like a flower blossoming or sunrise
or just something perfect.
The impossibility of it is what's so
beautiful,
like these guys are so unwilling
partners and they have such like a
desire to accomplish what they want to
accomplish to kick that guy in the face
from that position with vito has a
lifetime of this,
a lifetime of being able to not let you
do that and for you to first be willing
to be free enough to try it,
you know,
and,
and to,
to express it in that moment.
It is definitely hard,
but I,
I'm with you.
Fight doesn't intimidate me at all.
It,
you know,
a fight is a beautiful thing.
A fight is we fight for things all the
time.
You know,
it's a metaphor for life itself.
When they fight,
I think
people rightly so are concerned with the
idea of violence against someone who's
an unwilling participant and that's how
they think of fighting.
They think of it as this thing that they
want nothing to do with.
They don't want any violence in their
life.
They don't want anybody to hurt them and
I completely understand that.
I understand that position,
but that's not what it is.
When it's a competition.
I mean it's a tired expression because
I've said it too many times,
but my perception of what fighting is is
high level problem solving with dire
physical consequences
time and then the physical consequences
are what make it so special.
Yes,
no question.
No question.
Yeah,
[inaudible].
Make the gOod times better.
The the possibility that bad things can
happen to you and do sometimes happen
even to the great ones.
You see great fighters had been kod and
come back and you know,
there's,
that's,
there's something about that where you
realize like,
hey,
even fade or can get knocked out.
You know whaT I mean?
hey,
even anderson silva can play cocky and
get caught by that.
Chris weidman left hook.
I mean this is just,
this is just the game
and you know,
I think in asia in particular,
but there's different pockets of of how
these this is viewed and how the
philosophy of of connecting to martial
arts and fighting is viewed and in asia
you would see a certain amount of the
fighters would see being losing badly is
an opportunity,
a chance because to come back and win
again or to come back and show that
you're able,
you,
you were given the gift of trying and
failing.
You know whaT I mean?
Do know what you mean?
Yeah.
That's a great way to approach it.
It's a great way to look at it.
You know,
I mean that,
that there really is a lesson that the
average person can take in their life.
Like every time a person does have a bad
thing happened to them.
It's that terrible feelings and
opportunity to rise from the ashes.
Yeah.
And winning when it's,
when you're winning at everything and
things come easily to you that I'm sure
if it still feels good,
but when you've gone through really hard
times when you've been challenged by
something or do you drop lower,
the high of the success is so much
higher at so much of a longer journey.
Personally,
when we've spoke before and when we
talked about a cm punk,
when he was fighting the first time I
was like,
this is stupid,
you know,
and this guy is,
is pushing,
stacking himself into a position to try
to not fail by making the challenge so
difficult that even if he fails,
he don't really.
But this is fully different now.
Like now I'm,
I'm cheering for him because he was
humiliated like he was.
He didn't just fail.
He was humiliated.
He,
he in front of everybody was shown to
be.
People would judge them as weak or
people the judgment that he would feel
hIs bad and he sat.
I'll go do it again.
He,
we are now in a completely different
context because that's a guy who
epically failed in front of everybody
and then dealt with that and now says,
I will try the journey again and this
will make me a better person and I now I
fully endorse this.
I'm cheering for him.
Well,
he's now fighting a fighter who's
commensurate in talent and there's
nothing wrong with being a beginner in
martial arts,
but there's something wrong with
thinking that you can be a beginner in
fight.
Mickey go big time.
So it was a foolish venture and I wet my
approach to it was this is going to be a
very good lesson for people that are
fans of positive thinking and they think
that's enough.
That shit is not enough.
If you weigh 110 pounds,
you get positive.
Think your way to the bank.
For instance in Ghana,
still gonna punch your brains out.
There's just no way around it.
And a guy who has really very little
experience in martial arts and has
rudimentary control of his body.
I mean,
that's what I saw when I saw,
when I saw him training and was like,
oh my god,
he's killed.
He's not blind in that context and I,
but he belongs here and that's
everything's contextual.
Like,
just because I thought that was stupid.
It was stupid.
But that doesn't mean in this context I
can't look and go.
There's a guy who didn't need it.
He doesn't need to come back.
He doesn't need to try again.
He doesn't need to go into the gym and
I've been there.
You're in the jam and everyone's going
on,
man,
you did.
You did good.
I didn't do guy fucking failed miserably
in front of everybody.
And then show up there cleaning the mats
and work really hard and said I'm going
to try it again.
Uh,
and yes,
that fight still him and this guy still
should take place somewhere else.
One hundred percent.
I mean,
it shouldn't even be on the tuesday
night contender show.
No,
no.
It shouldn't.
Should be in some amateur event
somewhere.
That's really what they are.
They're,
they're guys learning how to compete.
Yeah.
Um,
during the first fight in the paper
view,
yeah,
that's fucking crazy,
but that has nothing to do with them.
That is a reflection on the company.
That's one of the choices that the
machine makes.
Um,
and then we also gave him a juicy
contract.
Yes,
in order to make that valid or viable to
make money off it.
But that again,
I think it makes it,
makes it deeper and harder and more
chances to fail epically and,
and I lost twice in a row and then still
want it to fight again and still because
it,
I really want it to.
And,
and it was important to me and it meant
something to me and I was going to
change as a human being by doing it and
I was ridiculed.
I can relate to what he's going through.
But I,
they ended on a little show in,
in winnipeg,
manitoba.
We know what I mean.
I would never have put myself in that
place to look bad.
But here he is and here it is and I'm
cheering for him as a store,
as a human being in a weird situation
that has been put himself into a deep,
dark,
hard spot and saying,
my way out of this is to try really hard
and really go in and and the chance all
of that I would want for him if I knew
him and he was my friend is to fight
your way through some adverse situations
to be able to be in it and find when
it's hard,
you discover I can handle the.
When it's hard,
I can,
I can get up when I've been dropped or I
can fight through not being able to
breathe.
If he loses and does that,
it will have been worth it for him.
No matter how much ridicule he'll take,
What was really weird watching them walk
to the cage was that he was approaching
it liga pro wrestling fight because he
had done so many of these pro wrestling
matches that he was walking to the cage
with like pro wrestling,
mannerisms,
everything and
all.
I was watching this and I,
you know,
I did like an internal head shake,
like fuck,
like this,
you can't.
It was a terrible idea.
Like whoever on everybody's side said
that he could fight micky gall,
you're out of your fucking mind.
Watch that kid fight once a kid is very
good on the ground,
very good at big and strong young
standups.
Not bad either,
you know,
and he's tough as shit and he's smart,
he's clever and he's mean.
He's mean fucker.
And that is at that stage he was maybe
one to know,
I think uh,
maybe two,
but it's still the lowest level that
there is in the entire elite world of
fighting.
Not that it didn't matter the way.
One,
like you saw it,
you saw the wait took that guy's back
and the way sinks hooks in when,
when he was on top and just delivered
that type.
Yeah.
That's.
And you're a hundred percent right.
What if somebody is watching that?
That is the reality of thinking.
I won't really worry.
I'll put myself in a situation that I
can't win,
but I've got guts and heart and I
believe I'm going to do it.
You get the metaphorical version of that
punch in the face.
If you go through life like that,
yes you do,
and you know what?
You shouldn't do it in fighting because
you don't want those punches in the
face.
If you can avoid them,
like if,
if you're in a situation where you're,
you want to prove your toughness and you
want to be battled against someone who's
of your skill level and try to figure
your way through the maze of this
contest.
That makes sense.
What doesn't make sense is getting
punched in the face unnecessarily and
when you fight,
in my opinion,
when I looked at that fight,
I was like,
micky gall is gonna smash him.
This is just how it's going to go.
There's very few fights where I can tell
you,
this is absolutely gonna happen.
Like,
here's a perfect example,
rob hoffeld dose on joe's,
uh,
against a colby covington.
I don't know what the fuck's gonna
happen.
No idea.
I don't know.
No,
we're going to get in there.
They're gonna.
Throw down.
Let's see.
Micky gall versus,
you know.
Um,
so I forgot to cm punk.
What's his real name?
Phil jackson.
No,
hardman fucking fill.
Whatever.
Yeah.
Cm punk.
What is it?
Jamie brooks.
Brooks brooks.
Phil brooks.
Sorry phil.
I was like,
well he's.
This is a terrible idea because he's
just going to get pr.
You can only get punched in the face so
many times in your life and you have a
number.
Whatever the number is,
everybody's different.
Mark hunt's number seems to be
extraordinarily high.
There's some people that could just take
it and this is true,
but you know,
you don't want it when you can avoid it
and he could.
He's not going to avoid it in that
fight.
I'm just going to get smashed and less
make it caught a crazy arm bar early in
the fight and that was what he gave him
the.
Yeah.
Other than that,
he's getting his face smashed in and you
should not do that if you don't have to
lead that.
As I remember when we spoke about it,
it's unconscious incompetence and that
if you don't know what you don't know,
like it's a really fucking weird place
to be and we go through life that a lot
of times
in a lot of different contexts until you
find out,
you know,
conscious incompetence where like,
oh fuck,
I don't know anything about this.
He wasn't even at that point.
Now he's at that point and he has a
lower level thing.
So,
and you know,
he didn't,
it was a mistake to start down this
road.
But you're down at now.
You're on it now.
So I guess,
you know,
it seems to me that,
I mean he's taken what,
two years since I've been about two
years getting there and we've
subsequently got to see micky gall and
some contests against some really tough
guys and yeah.
Yeah,
beat some good guys.
And we got to see like,
okay,
this kid is fucking for real,
which is what we suspected all along,
but we don't know anything about phil.
We haven't seen him spar,
we haven't seen retrained.
But from what I saw when I first saw him
training the first,
you know,
when I first saw him sparring and moving
around,
I was like,
got damaged a lot of work to be done,
like,
you know,
like first steps of everest work to be
done.
It's like,
this is,
um,
we're not talking about a guy who has a
deep background in martial arts.
Like brock lesnar,
no wrestling is absolutely a martial
art.
He was a legit top of the food chain
amateur wrestler.
He was a fucking monster
and a physical monster.
I mean that.
And a psychological monster like
fighting his skills for sure.
But it's your body and the mind and when
you are a heavy competitor,
when you focus,
when you're able to focus in the
deepest,
most fearful conditions,
a brock lesnar did that,
you know,
and uh,
physically when you're aware,
like you said,
we're aware of where your body is in
space and how to control.
And that can take a lifetime.
And uh,
so it's a weird one,
but I think,
yeah,
something you also develop as a child,
as a young kid.
Like when you're in your developmental
years,
13,
14,
15,
you're body's growing and it's growing
into whipping kicks and punches and
shooting takedowns and landing chokes.
Your body develops that way.
When you're a full grown man in your
thirties and then you're starting to
throw roundhouse kicks and front kicks
in.
You're,
your body's all goofy and shit and
doesn't,
doesn't want to listen.
Right?
It's not pliable.
It's not elastic.
It says that you're a different animal.
You can still learn anything.
You at 50 years old,
you can take up anything in the world.
You can take anything and you should.
Yeah,
you shouldn't be shitting,
you know,
go into the nfl where they.
Or if you start to play a piano when
you're 50,
you should learn to play piano and show
all your friends,
you know,
the song or.
But you can't go like,
you know,
be in a concert,
piano scenario where you're going to
fail and,
and doing it and saying,
you know,
I believe doesn't make a difference when
he doesn't physically or mentally or
psychologically do these things.
But I still think learning and growing
and chasing things and self improvement
is the root of who we are.
I agree.
Yeah.
I think it is too.
But you can't be a 34 year old man who's
never box a day your life and have a
goal
to in 12 months,
fight loma chanko no.
It's never going to happen.
If it does happen,
it's gonna be a disaster and that there
are giant exceptions like one in a
million of things where people do
things,
but there's always some other
explanation.
And often it is as a youth,
they created the neuro pathways in the
physicality and the connection to their
body.
You know,
I was uh,
I did gymnastics when I was a kid and I
love it.
It's great big.
Yeah.
I loved it.
And,
and,
and you know,
it helps you physically understand where
your body is.
And so later on in life,
I was always at least okay at sports
because I understood how to move my body
in space and I understood where my hand
was compared to my foot and how I
balanced.
And to learn that as a child,
somebody who was a master of something
as a kid who had 30 picks up.
Another thing,
it has some really advanced learning
abilities.
There are exceptions that we see rare
exceptions,
but,
but you're right,
I mean reality still reality.
I wonder too,
if those exceptions are genetic,
I wonder if like maybe perhaps someone
in their family.
It was a great athlete and it's
transferred through their genes,
which I am as I get older,
a firm believer in,
um,
I just don't think we know enough about
what transfers through genes.
But there's some freaky shit I see in my
kids in particular where I go,
okay,
that is my fucking personality.
That's something.
And I'm not teaching her to do this.
This is something that's in her like
this.
The repetitive like exercise,
like doing things over and over again.
Obsessive lee,
like there's some weird shit that like,
am I wonder if that's a neuropathway
that's passed down through the dna.
I mean,
it just seems like there could be a
person who's never engaged in athletics,
but maybe their grandfather was like a
world champion boxer.
And then one day they put on the gloves
and then they just sorta like start
moving around and the coach was like,
hey,
what the fuck's going on here?
Where did you learn?
Or three job like that.
I'm forgetting.
Francis and ghana's coach's name,
I forget his name is fernando lopez.
Yes.
He's a wonderful guy,
a smart guy.
Really?
He's been around like the best of the
best through europe.
So in Cameroon to France and these areas
and he's seen the best of the best that
that genetic crop of humans has to
offer.
And then francis and got it walks into
his gym and you've talked to yo next
time you see fernand to ask him about
this because you see his eyes light up
like that thing where this like a color
in the eye.
And he's like,
you know,
I just knew,
like he said,
I watched him do things in his awareness
of his body and how he could physically
express himself.
He said he'd just never seen anything
like it.
And this is,
you know,
week one in the gym.
He said,
first sparring session,
he didn't really know how to fight yet,
but he said he saw him adapting and
learning within the round against
somebody who knew how to fight and you
see it in his eyes.
He.
He literally found fucking unicorn
that just strolled in off the street and
came in and then he was like,
man,
if he's had some work ethic,
if he is,
you know,
if,
if he's passionate about this,
if he can commit and learn and all that,
it goes physically,
genetically speaking,
this human being,
the length of his bones,
the speed of his neurology,
all of these things.
He said you just knew and you see it in
his face.
You're like,
oh fuck.
That must have been wild.
It must have been wild to,
to experience that when you have a
lifetime of seeing.
Yeah.
It's like that scene in the color of
money.
I don't know if you ever saw that movie
was with paul move Paul Newman and tom
cruise.
When Paul Newman,
here's tom cruise,
break the balls for the first time.
It turns a rose.
What the fuck is going on over here?
And he looks over and he sees his kid.
There's,
there's certain people that just have
this crazy talent and when someone has
been around for a long time as a coach
and had a bunch of untalented or
reasonably talented are very talented
people.
This,
this big stew of humans come into the
gym and you see that one unicorn that
steps in and he's also a case where his
father,
I mean he doesn't have a backer,
he didn't have a background in martial
arts before you started training,
but his father was a great street
fighter and it's entirely possible that
something was carried on through him or
something was present in both.
That allowed them both to be capable of
doing that rather than the learn to pass
because we don't know how that passes
genetically from behavior.
We know that genetically we may behave
similar to our parents,
our kids.
We don't know if that came from that.
But,
uh,
I,
I just,
I'm the oldest weirdly uncomfortable
thinking about genetics because I don't
like the idea that we're limited by
them.
And I know that we're not on some level,
but we are,
we are,
but we're not going to play basketball.
He,
yes,
since lebron james.
But if we identified.
No,
no,
we're not where we do,
it's not going to go well.
Okay.
No,
there's some,
there's definitely some truths.
I mean I'm five foot six on a tall day.
Like that is a genetic limitation that
is undeniable.
Right?
But if we're looking at things and we
decide that our genes,
if you've seen the movie gattica I've
ever seen them and I did see them moving
a long time ago.
That's one of my favorite movies ever.
Matt.
So ethan hawke,
ethan hawke.
Yeah.
I always think of him as uma thurman.
Yeah,
she's in it.
But I know,
but I think of him because he used to be
married to her.
I'm like,
oh,
that's houma thurman thurman in that
movie,
his brother is genetically superior to
him,
but he beats his brother in the swimming
contests all the time.
And at the end his brothers like,
how are you doing this?
And he said,
I never saved anything for the swim
back.
I was just going to swim to the other
side,
and his brothers like there is no
fucking other side,
but it was.
I know it's a movie,
but it was a mindset,
right,
and the truth is that like talent.
Okay,
so you're talented at certain things.
Jamie's talents,
a certain things.
Francis and Ghana,
talented talent multiplied by effort
equals skill and skill multiplied by
effort equals accomplishment.
So effort counts twice,
right?
Effort counts fucking twice,
but then you get effort with a talented
guy with freak genetics like a lebron
james or a Michael Jordan or brock
lesnar,
and then you get some crazy
results.
Yes.
Oh,
big time.
And the guy who doesn't have the the
talent but had effort twice.
Effort was applied twice.
We'll go as far as the man or woman will
go as far as they possibly could to
actualize their true potential by
committing themselves to,
to effort and not going well.
I can't do it.
So forget it.
By applying effort over and over and
over again.
And then once you've developed talent,
more effort to take that talent and do
something that twice used effort,
we'll get you as far as you possibly
can.
If you say,
well,
I'm not gifted,
I'm not talented so I won't put any
effort.
You have no idea how far you can go.
So I absolutely cannot beat francis and
new,
but by not thinking that I'm too limited
by my jeans and continuing to apply
effort,
regardless of my jeans,
I can get to the best possible place I
can as an individual.
Do you know what I mean?
So I think that that on some you don't
want to go down some road that you
cannot be accomplished,
but you also don't want to not go down
roads because you're not genetically
predisposed to them.
I think effort can get you somewhere.
It definitely can get you somewhere.
But I think what we're talking about
here is what I love about life is that
it's messy.
Yeah.
That there's not,
it's not one plus one is two zeros and
ones.
It's just there's a bunch of factors.
Does a lot of shit going on man.
And that's why when something magical
takes place,
when you get a,
you know,
uh,
george st pierre,
or when you,
you get a mighty mouse,
when you get someone who's like,
whoa,
look at that,
like this,
there's so many factors that lead you to
be gennady golovkin.
Now there's so many different things
have to fall into place.
Or here's a guy,
like,
how about michael bisping?
Michael bisping is just one of the
toughest motherfuckers ever example.
Yeah.
But you found the perfect.
Michael bisbing is one of the toughest
motherfuckers ever.
He's not extraordinarily talented in any
one form of mma.
He's not like the fastest guy.
He's not the strongest guy.
He doesn't have this great background in
brazilian jujitsu where he's just a
worldclass strangler.
And if he gets your back,
you're fucked.
There's none of those things.
He's just tough as fuck.
And he's one of the most mentally strong
guys.
Like even tim kennedy who was here the
other day,
tim kennedy's like,
god,
I hate to give them a compliment,
but he's so fucking tough.
Can't.
You can't deny them.
You
can't.
So,
and,
and that goes right back to this,
and I think this is at the root of
questions about life,
was michael bisbing genetically tough?
Is he genetically mentally tough or did
work really hard and just push himself
through things and that one day when it
got really fucking tough,
he didn't give up,
which taught him that he shouldn't give
up,
which taught him to go even further,
which made him push himself like,
or was it in all likelihood?
It's both.
But michael bisping free of that effort
to continue to because what's his name?
Think of the mentally toughest guy that
I'm just,
I have a thing with names sometimes.
Even names I know I'll describe.
You guys got a chain and he's howling
and he does power slam,
but I can't think of ramp.
I can't think of rampage,
but I'm a big elbows.
You've had.
I'm probably on the podcast,
a tough hairy chest.
Um,
uh,
who am I thinking of 170 pounds fought
demian maia.
I'm matt brown.
Matt brown.
Oh,
south.
Yeah.
But that's exactly what I can literally
literally say all these things,
but the name will escape me.
It's a strange thing.
Happens to me too.
I will.
I worked with john.
We're early in the morning,
right?
I worked with john ramm dean for years
is one of my best friends and he would
literally just see it in my eyes,
just like I won't have the name and I'll
throw out one or two of those factoids.
And you always had it.
It'd be like matt brown.
So that's why having good friends to
work with is great.
Will know your.
Yeah.
But talking to him about brandon on the
phone,
I,
I'm doing an interview with them.
I said,
you're one of the mentally toughest guys
there is.
And he said that,
I don't think I am.
He said,
if I think I'm mentally tough for one
moment I will not do all of the things
necessary to walk in mentally tough.
He said,
he's like,
man,
I am not mentally tough.
The mental toughness is a result of all
of the hard work and preparation that I
have done to be able to do it in that
moment.
And you heard it in his voice.
He had no doubt that this was so and I
think he's right.
He's right.
I think he's ready to,
but he's also mentally tough because he
also does those things,
but one of the things that about matt
brown that separates him is that empties
out in the cage.
He separates himself from the pack
because he.
He's so ferocious like that guys for
roche's.
Remember when,
when he stepped into the cage,
we were watching.
I think we're doing a fight companion,
but we're maybe we were wearing anyway
when,
when he stepped into the cage and fought
diego sanchez,
when,
when he stepped into the octagon and
screamed and roared,
it was literally like an animal.
I mean it was,
it was for veracity defined and that's
just how we fight,
man.
That guy just empties out like whatever
the fuck he's got.
He's not holding anything back,
man.
He,
he goes for it.
And that's why I think when we were
talking about fight and art,
to me that's an art of human expression.
Like I think that is to be a capable.
I mean whether you're you're doing jazz
or punk rock,
it's human expression.
Whether your matt brown or your some
elegant mover,
it's still the same art at its root.
But you remember that elbow,
he fired on diego sanchez fight.
It was there.
And there are these moments.
Are there a lot when you're analyzing,
fighting and looking at it from that
other perspective,
these fight ending moments are there.
They're there are way more often than
these guys realize.
But when they spot them like matt did in
that moment,
this is.
I have a free shot from an angle.
Time has slowed down enough that I see
it.
I can see the little red arc of where
it's going and I'm going to put this,
I'm going to end this fight it.
There's a visceral like,
like it's.
Here it is.
When people look at you see it,
see just like that.
That is fucking art to me.
But watch the lefthand,
the reach and the hold and it's like
there is no doubt what,
what's happening here.
There is no doubt
going to happen.
Go cinches is another curious example
because he's also a guy who is
ferocious,
like a ferociously tough guy,
but there's always been something about
his movements that makes him come up
short against the best of the best.
And I mean you're talking about a guy
who's so fucking mentally tough as well.
Like I always bring his fight against
jake ellenberger who is a brutal
knockout artists at one 70 and diego
really.
I mean diego fought at 1:45,
remember?
And diego really is a tweener.
He's a little too small for 55.
I don't know how the fuck he made it to
1:45.
He basically starved as body away and
probably did some irreversible damage.
But he feels like his movements are
always just shy of elite.
And I've always wondered what is that
like?
It's almost like even if you see that,
go back to that clip again,
but you don't have to.
It's okay.
But there's something about even the way
he steps in,
he's not stepping the way a tj dillashaw
steps,
you know what I'm saying?
He's so,
I,
I see it as his sort of intention.
It's his over into god that is so nasty,
nasty and so perfect.
But I see he wants it badly.
Like he is.
He's over engaged.
I think it's psychological as much as
anything I would say in,
in albuquerque.
Look at that.
The placement of the lefthand there.
There's just no doubt where this is
going.
It's perfect.
It's.
And it is the moment that matt brown
created,
like he created that moment,
see hairy chest until jerry.
That's fun.
That's one of my reminder cues,
right?
Uh,
but,
uh,
I think so I watched diego train in
albuquerque and I love that guy.
I was there doing interviewing cub who
is my favorite artists probably to watch
for many reasons.
I'm not really sure exactly why people
can't tell you why their favorite band
is their favorite band.
But I can tell there aren't many things
that you can describe,
but I was there to interview him for
monster zim.
It's a website in South Korea that when
I became a freelancer,
they were like,
we'd like to give you some work.
I'm like,
well,
that'd be amazing.
We'd like you to go.
He just fought.
Do whoa choice.
We'd like you to go interview mr.
Cub swanson.
I'm like,
this is bad ass.
It's like my favorite fighter.
I'm going to send me to albuquerque,
and then I hung out in the gym and
analyze them and watched and made notes
about what I could and diego and super
intense and he does everything super
intense and and as much as he loves yoga
and the different types of yoga and
meditation has allowed him to do it
differently.
That hyper intensity I think doesn't
allow the sort of soft relaxation that's
necessary to really do what you're
describing.
You know,
I know what you're saying.
Like the one of the things that people
don't understand about striking hard and
having real power is that you're not
fully tense through the entire movement.
There's a lot of parts of striking where
the momentum starts and you're almost
like completely loose.
Like up until instance,
before the point of contact and then
it's,
there's this,
there's this weird thing that real
knockout artists have that you don't see
in these fucking tense windmill guys.
Windmill guys are too tight.
Totally.
But a guy like ray robinson will throw
up,
like there's a,
there was a gene fullmer ray robinson
kao clip from the other night.
Uh,
I was,
I was watching online.
I must have watched like 13 times in a
row.
But you watch them land this thing.
It was a left hook,
but you watched the punchline.
He liked jesus,
like this nap that,
that guy had.
But that snap is not,
it's not,
it's not fully tents.
Here it is right here.
Like,
look how soft it is.
Simple.
Yeah.
Soft.
But look at that lead,
that left hook right there.
That one's softens them up,
ties him up.
But everything is like,
yeah,
swimming.
Yeah.
I mean it's just,
he was an amazing boxer dude.
And you're talking about a guy who had
like 100 and something fights,
right?
It's almost gentle,
Like he's soft is the right word.
Suppleness there.
So
there's a calmness,
there's a relaxation and mentally too,
like you know,
that idea of there's a storm going on in
the middle of this,
this calm area,
that gentleness,
that,
that calmness has to be in your mind to
allow you to do this.
And that's where diego is,
that man.
Just look at that,
that's fucking incredible.
And that left hook right here,
here it is pink yet.
And even just to create that moment and
to see that moment,
you know,
and to set it up and lay traps and see
when the guys moving his hands down,
see when he's coming forward,
see his patterns and 10 they can do
those things.
Yup,
yup,
yup.
But it's that kind of power in that left
hook that does not come from.
That's just this little twists that he
does like come on,
but here
it is right here in slow mo.
Bang.
And it's just hip.
And so I did.
I'm sure you saw it or I think you saw
it.
I did a little breakdown of your kicks.
I did see that.
And it's just,
that's what I was.
So zooming in on was this double
paulson.
That's real,
that's.
That is the neurology of high athletic
performance.
So I have these friends that I've
developed,
I've gathered over the years and I love
what I do,
man,
like I'm happy every single day and a
big part of it is I've met these people
that I have these conversations with and
sometimes they're very long and deep and
and they've some.
I have friends that are a phd
psychologists and this one guy dr stu
mcgill.
Do you know who he is?
His name now?
You've probably heard that name.
I'm sure somebody has mentioned it
because you're around different athletic
types of all types.
He is the world's foremost expert in the
spinal cord and neurology of athletic
performance,
spinal cord.
The spinal cord and how and your
neurology and your nerves and how your
nervous system and george st pierre has
worked with him a lot.
He,
if you asked him about him this week,
he would talk about them extensively.
So dr stu and I became friends and it's
a big compliment because he sought me
out based on seeing my work and saying
that guy knows some things I want to
talk to him,
which was a plaque and deep compliment
to me and now we became friends and we
chat all the time and one of the things
we constantly talk about is the double
pulse in neurology and people talk about
fast twitch fiber.
It's not a fiber as that's just terms
we've started to hear.
It's a fast twitch neurology.
It's,
it's a base,
a fast ball hitters have it.
You know what I mean?
That neurology where you,
you,
there's a pulse of tension and then a
complete relaxation until the pulse of
tension.
Again,
the bruce lee's one inch punch was the
simple example of that,
but that is how that is the neurology of
high athletic performance and that's
what I zoomed in on when I was looking
at your kid because you can see it quite
clearly.
There is the moment,
there's the relaxing those and it ends
up being more of a whip and stewart Dr.
Stewart has all these incredible
analogies because he's examined this in
so many different angles and layers,
which is the beauty of analyzing
anything for years and he'll use terms
like you can't shoot a cannon out of a
canoe and you think about that and
you're like,
of course with canoes all wobbly,
but if it's tense and then shoots or you
can't push a rope,
right?
You push a rope,
right,
and so,
but you can whip a rope through tension,
relaxation and tension again,
and that neurology is the neurology of
high performance and george,
you talked to george about neurology.
He'll go deep down some shit to george
st pierre because he studied this to
understand himself and what he was doing
at a high level with doctors do.
But it is a fascinating thing because
when you think we often will say
fighting is 90 percent mental sipping.
This cup is 100 percent mental.
You know,
my brain told my body to reach out and
do it.
My brain made the choice.
I activated everything,
use,
it's all your brain,
everything and once you get to a high
level of performance,
you know how to punch and kick and you
train like crazy and you make the things
happen by themselves almost by trading
so much they take so little attention
and decision making.
It becomes about maximizing your nervous
system,
how your nervous system.
And I think that's true of almost
anything history right there.
Yeah.
That susie training with george and dr
stu.
I couldn't see his face.
Yeah,
that's true.
It looks like a bar guy and to be honest
george.
Yeah,
but got.
I'm whipping the ball around.
Yeah.
I'm not sure exactly what he's doing or
why they're dumbbell press,
but I'll put you in touch with them
often.
So it's like a,
it looks like he's got some heavy weight
at the end of a rope.
Yeah.
And I guess engaging the core through
the use of,
you know,
probably asking him to only engage
certain things to counter balance the
movement
prize,
to see george waring,
your typical a running shoe when he's
training with the thick heel.
And you know,
I'm still surprised to this day when I
see I'm going to talk about neurology
and activating muscles and tissues.
Like there's so many athletes is still
train with those big cushy bottomed
running shoes.
I mean I think that is crazy.
Big time.
It's weird.
It's weird,
mean you should be doing that kind of
shit barefoot.
Especially a fighter.
You fight barefoot.
You should be wearing nothing on your
feet.
The only thing connecting you to a
stable surface is your foot.
Yeah,
I agree 100 percent.
And sometimes when we're trying to make
sense of these things,
we go to multiple different sort of
perspectives of it.
So I'll take what I learned from dr stu
and he's just my friend now as well.
So I like hanging out and chatting with
him about like way out there aspects of
these things.
But you talk to irwin [inaudible] as
well,
who has a different sphere of connecting
to this kind of thing in erewhon starts
with the foot and you've had urban on
the.
Yeah,
and he starts with the foot and
everything else.
It makes sense,
right?
I go to throw a punch and the important
part is going to be my foot through the
leg,
through the hip,
through the core and and relaxed until
the moment that it hits.
But then they'll start song is the same.
when I asked nick's.
Excuse me when I asked nick curse on
about training athletes,
like what's the thing that he thinks
fighters work on the most?
He's like foot strength.
I was like,
wow.
And I thought about it like,
well of course.
Right?
That's how you push off.
That's how you move.
Your feet are weak and they get tired.
You can't move.
Well,
which I've experienced.
I'm sure you've experienced when your
feet are weak and tired.
Like if you.
If you don't run and then you try to run
one of the first things,
you get tired of your feet.
The very worst injury I've ever had in
my life by far was plantar fasciitis of
both feet.
My last fight and I was through training
and everything and then I had my fight
in montreal and the whole strategy was
put,
getting to a place where I could be safe
and use better knowledge of the
situation to fatigue the other guy.
So the whole,
a lot of the seven or eight minutes of
the fight took place with me,
pressuring him against the fence,
just driving off both feet,
pressuring against the fence to try to
land things or make create lines for
different weapons.
And it's only eight minutes,
but eight minutes of intense drive from
my feet.
And then we went on vacation the very
next day and that night we grabbed
margarita's and we walked around the
resort and then my feet were destroyed
for a acutely,
for three or four days.
Like I couldn't walk.
And the inflammation was so unbelievably
bad.
It was like bricks.
And,
uh,
even for months after it was,
did you ask him,
uh,
tried to ice I ice or I would get in
immediately into the cold pool and spend
the day in the cold pool drinking
tequila and hopes that it would help.
And it kinda did
foot pain is,
that's one of the things that are hurt.
Dominick cruz in his comeback fight when
he fought tj dillashaw,
you notice he was kind of limping a
little.
We were attributed to the leg kicks.
He said that's not the case.
He said what was going on was he had
plantar fasciitis because,
you know,
he had multiple injuries that he was
recovering from during that training
camp.
And wHen he got knee surgery and he came
back from that and he tore his groin.
He tried to like really ramp up his
training.
He was doing a lot of sprinting and a
lot of different things with his feet,
you know,
because obviously he's very footwork
intensive with his fighting and he
fucked his feet up.
Man.
His feet just weren't in conditioned to
do the kind of stuff that he used to be
able to do.
And the first thing he got was plantar
fasciitis shop had it too.
He told me it was the worst things he's
ever had.
I mean,
yeah,
think of this for the big picture
meaning of this for dominic.
So you got somebody else and there are
going about fighting and their,
their career as a martial artist,
a competitive fighter one way.
And dominic goes about a different way.
And through dominic's choices,
uh,
moving training,
footwork,
he avoids a lot of the damage that these
guys will take.
But you can't avoid.
Something's going to go right.
So instead of taking,
getting kicked a lot and punched in the
head and taking all those things,
the training necessary to make that not
happen,
fucks up something else.
Like you can't get away from it.
You're going to work yourself until your
body gives up.
Even dom brilliantly finding a way to
work outside of taking the damage that
they take still could not get away from
damaging his body.
Tj dillashaw versus cody garbrandt.
The rematch is one of the most
intriguing parts of the year for me.
I'm really,
really curious about that fight because
I know those guys were tightly matched
in the gym and I know that cody correct
him with a big right hand before tj put
him away and so it was.
He was stunned.
I mean he got rocked and I believe when
cody cracked and it was towards the end
of the round,
he was.
Yeah,
and so he had an opportunity to recover.
I mean,
who knows if he had caught that right
hand the first minute of the round what
had gone on,
but when tj recovered from that and then
lend that head kick and then knocked him
out and put them away,
you got to see like,
oh,
what a high level high stakes game these
two guys are playing and you know,
tj has through bang ludwig has really
radically improved his movement,
his footwork,
his angles,
his approach.
He's so versatile with his ability to
switch stances,
his ability.
I mean he's constantly cutting angles
and striking as you switching stances
and there's so much information coming
at you.
If you're fighting him,
your,
your brain's overloaded.
If you're not used to that.
And even the guys who used to train with
them,
I believe in alpha male,
are not used to what he's doing now.
I agree.
Because it's a.
It's a.
It's a at a far higher level that said,
cody still has a fucking missile in his
right hand.
It's so god damn fast.
His hand speed is so fast and his,
his fluidity and efficiency in his
boxing is so good.
It's just a very,
very interesting fight for me.
That's about as good as it gets right
now.
Like from the raw materials of those
guys and the skills that they have.
But I,
I'm definitely with you as far as that.
My deep curiosity of the choices of the
coaches because,
and you've talked to some of them
different ones,
you know,
I've got a few key friends that I talked
to on a very regular basis.
And so what it will take,
what we would decide to do to train to
make our guy the best in the world or
try to be the best in the world in 10
months.
If we take a different strategy and we
start to build them to be the best in
the world in three years,
it's a different game and that's what
dwayne,
dwayne is sad.
We will and it's,
it's fucking hard work for dwayne to
like,
that's the thing that people won't
necessarily appreciate it.
They'll be like,
oh,
he's a brilliant coach.
That's nonstop constant searching and
examining and trial and error and
reinterpreting his language of
understanding where the,
where the chaos is and understanding,
you know,
can we make this guy believes
something's happening or are we too deep
in it that he doesn't think that and it
fails.
Like what levels of misdirection or too
deep,
how good is he?
And when I talked to them leading up to
that one,
it was like,
you know,
the conversation was about her making
cody believe and anticipate something
wrong.
And that's the root of all of all
combat,
right?
Like you make me think this is coming
and I do this.
Me in the body and the layers,
the multiple layers,
like you just said,
overloading the ability to.
You're trying to catalog what's coming
and how you chunk that,
uh,
we don't necessarily understand.
So your brain be going,
okay,
this is all the stuff from the left
which happens when this happened or the,
the,
the legs or doing this or you're running
algorithms in your brain and we don't
know.
I don't know what yours is.
I don't know how you categorize my
threats.
I don't know whether you categorize
anything from my right hand or anything
in combination or if you're watching the
patterns of my shoulders,
I have no idea.
So dwayne and anybody else playing with
this concept is trying to figure out how
you'll read this and use that against
you.
And to me,
that's the layer of complete mindblowing
nature that like,
what did you say?
Chests with dire consequences or
problem?
Solvable problem.
Fucking hard.
those problems are now how many there
are.
That's the game.
And,
and it can be done at this level because
their skills are so good.
they're minds are so good.
They're physically so good,
they're capable,
they're fearless,
they are confident.
They have all of those raw materials and
now we're playing a game that most of us
cannot comprehend and they've also
sparred countless hours together so they
stand each other and they've told each
other lies for long periods.
He lies on lies.
I one time went with a.
I worked for a company called the score
fighting series.
It was a brilliant show like it was kind
of cannabis.
Bella tore like it was on the same
network and they aired bella tour and it
was very,
very good developmental league stuff and
that company brought in forrest griffin
and then a bunch of poker players and
they were on a train together and
contest winners on the thing.
Got to ride on this train with forrest
griffin and a bunch of poker high level
pro poker players and I was there and
that was the first time I met forrest
and this is a killer,
smart dude,
but you watch these poker players who
were all riding together and they all
know each other and they were just
telling each other lies all the time.
Trying to tell stories about things that
represent the fact that they are,
you know,
conservative when really they're risk
takers are trying to tell each other
things that make them think they're
crazy,
but really they're calculating like they
are telling each other lies ongoing and
the gambling with each other and shit,
it's completely degenerate generative,
but that's the kind of thing that's
happening on some level with these,
the high level fighters to making them
think certain things about what they
will do or believe they'll do almost
everything they say.
Um,
we see the fans and the audience we
should assume is a game chip is like a,
something to make the other one believes
something that might in that moment,
let me land that kick.
If he thinks that I'm,
you know,
whatever,
right?
Let's manipulative stuff.
And at that level that is just so
unbelievably fascinating.
It really is.
When the stakes are so high,
you know,
the kick lands,
you're a hero,
the kick mrs.
and you get caught with a left hook.
You're a loser.
You know,
there's just so much at stake with every
single choice you make and all,
all those choices have to be almost
subconscious or semi-conscious because
you've got to be in the zen state,
you gotta to be flowing so everything
has to be prepared.
You have to have,
you know,
while you're in there,
you have
to have no regrets.
You have to be able to just flow and you
have to be able to capitalize on any
movement,
any,
any opening,
you see you got to pounds and you have
to be in condition to execute all these
things so you have to have had the
physical discipline and the mental
fortitude to push yourself through
training to a level that you probably
didn't think you could get to
and,
and I want to pounce with the opening,
but what if it's a lie,
right?
Right.
But what if matt brown line on that
thing was actually.
That one would be hard to be alive,
but there are other ones where it feels
like that one little opening.
But instead tj is going to catch you or
cody's line.
Do you opt to draw you into something
so god damn fast,
to his hand,
speed is so ridiculously fast.
I go back to the tom sell modified and
I'll made.
Has really never been the same again.
I'll made a.
Going into that fight was undefeated,
was thought to be the dark horse in the
division like will look or future world
champion and cody lit him up like a
christmas tree and the way he did it was
so definitive that you like jesus,
like there can be no doubt this guy has
real world championship potential.
Yeah,
and I think that the duane ludwig factor
is so fucking huge.
Really,
really do.
And I,
I've seen dwayne's work in like dwayne,
unlike a lot of guys has notebooks,
binders full of ideas and his system is
a,
it's a very declared system.
It's not like loosely based where we
always work off the jab.
We've got good footwork.
No,
there's none of that.
Like there's a system to his,
like he has a belt system to his style
and his style is based on for people
don't know.
Dwayne was a world class kickboxer
worldclass,
muy thai fighter,
I mean fought ramon dekkers,
mean,
fought some of the best of the best,
had some amazing fights in both mma and
in kickboxing and he was a really
talented guy and then transitioned on to
being a coach and the obsession that he
has towards coaching is really at a
higher level than even his obsession
towards fighting and he talks about
that,
that his passion is teaching people.
He loves it.
He loves being able to mold students and
he's found the perfect muse or the
perfect willing participant in tj and tj
and him have a very unique friendship
and very unique student mentorship sort
of relationship.
It's really,
really interesting to watch the two of
them together.
Wild now the super jam with 20 guys and
then you've got a,
and dwayne has tons of athletes too,
but a but a commitment and connection to
tj.
Then you've got matt hume and demetrius
like you've got a few of these guys who
are just like,
we you,
we will funnel all of my experience
through everything through this super
athlete,
but like you talk about those books,
the only way that you get to a point of
this level of mastery that we're talking
about is that you must go down some
fucking road for six months that amounts
to nothing so that you learned that road
isn't the road and the only way and you
can't give up too early.
And what if by going down at long enough
some different concepts about how you
switch your feet in a certain moment.
You think maybe that ain't it,
but you have discovered that by pushing
through some of these concepts long
enough,
you find it so you stick with it long
enough and it turns out now dwayne or
anybody else reaching that level of
mastery has gone down some rabbit hole
for months or years and discovered the
only value they got out of it was what?
No,
there's lots of value.
That wasn't the rabbit hole and the.
The process of searching this rabbit
hole has made me better at searching
rabbit holes,
so those two values,
some of the stacks of his books are
things that didn't work and he will
probably appreciate those just as much
as any of the ones that did it was also.
Tj is approach is really interesting to
me because tj is obsessed with
improvement and knowledge and he keeps
talking about his fight iq and you know,
him and dwayne,
I've been around them,
I've trained with them,
have worked out with him.
I've watched him coach tj and I mean
they're,
they're constantly working on the
minutia.
That constant working on finite details
and improving every single aspect and
tightening things up.
And it's really interesting.
Tj is a fucking open book man.
I mean he's uh,
he's,
he,
you can talk to that guy about anything
and he's considering it.
He's thinking and he's like,
oh,
okay,
I see what you're doing.
Like he's,
he's a guy who's always trying to take
in information
that's.
So these are the things when we do watch
this kind of thing,
whether it is martial arts or even jazz
or football or whatever,
there are these lessons that are there
like we should do that corresponds to go
through life doing that.
We're not supposed to look at tj
dillashaw and go,
wow,
isn't that crazy,
that guy,
if we do that,
our lives will get better.
Right?
Like I,
I got to.
So I get to work for tsn in Canada,
which is like espn in the states and we,
I'm myself and erin brought instead or
like the two person division that talks
about about a ufc and fighting.
And uh,
we uh,
they went and when george was fighting
michael,
they went and said,
you know,
could you approach your friends with
george and his people?
Could you approach them about doing a
half hour long documentary on him about
his comeback and training and stuff?
And I did.
And at first george was open to it and
is randolph his manager.
I was like,
oh god,
I hear the word documentary and I know
what that means.
It's going to be months.
And is going to be cameras and it's
going to be a distraction.
I said I'll just travel with george and
I have the best producer,
simon,
the best producer we have and we'll just
travel with them.
And they saId yes.
And so I got to travel with george for a
month,
six weeks off and on New York,
la montreal life eating ice cream
training with freddie roach.
Yeah.
That was interesting.
When is this going to come out?
It did come up before,
so mostly in Canada,
but I'm going to send a message that I'm
going to send a message immediately
after we get off here to simon and the
rest of them and say where is that right
now?
And then I'll,
I'll tweet it out because he had learned
a lot.
Oh man,
it changed my life because you don't get
to be around the greats of the greats
and study them.
And we're friends so I can talk to him
like we hang out here.
I got to fucking train karate with his
team,
like point karate,
you know.
So it'd be,
oh,
robin's training with us today.
What kind of point karate training do
they do and do they do this to practice
like blitzing and just think of this
like you were big on point karate like
2012,
2013 and I didn't disagree but I didn't
really get there.
It is.
There it is.
Yeah,
it.
Oh fuck.
It was so magical to see like.
And I wasn't just like,
how does he kick?
I'm like,
how does he think and why does he do the
things he does and why?
What's his motivation?
And it really made me a better human
being getting to do that,
but so what I didn't really connect to
us.
Sometimes there's something so simple
and we don't see it because we're in
deep enough or whatever we're in,
but the idea of point karate people
right away say,
well they're just touching each other so
I could.
true.
So if I'm training to just touch you,
I'm not trying to hurt you.
Okay.
That seems like that's not valuable when
you're training to not.
Let me even fucking touch you.
If you can't get touched by me.
How hard.
Impossible as it for me to hit you
clean,
you know what I mean?
If your movement and your,
your defensive systems and your
management of the,
of the distance between our weapons and
targets are such that I can't fucking
touch you.
How can I hurt you?
Right?
If I can't even get touchy with my
glove.
Well,
the thing is,
here's what I think about point fighting
and what I think was valid about it is
if you're just doing point fighting with
a point fighter,
it is extremely frustrated.
I fought and point fighting tournaments
when I was competing and we.
There was.
I came from a full contact taekwondo
background and we fought in these
tournaments and the object was to knock
people unconscious and you would fight,
you know,
they would have three minute rounds and
you would fight and you would try to
kick people into another.
Very similar in Canada,
what we.
There was a lot of people that are
trained with that openly dismissed point
fighting and the reason why they openly
dismissed point fighting was because
they would stop every time someone would
get touched and I would be like,
well,
in the real world or everybody would say
in the real world,
you don't just stop when you get
touched,
you keep fighting.
And so with our techniques,
a lot of it,
you would hit someone once and they
would counter and then you'd set up the
big shot afterwards.
like this is part of the thing and if
the referee kept stopping you,
then you would never get anything done.
But my thinking once I got into mma was
okay,
yeah,
but if you can do that and do the other
things,
it's like people dismiss taekwondo
because they're like,
we'll talk one doe.
You know,
you get taken to the ground,
you get your legs kicked out.
Absolutely.
But if you have
takedown defense and you know more thai,
you can.
We'll kick someone into another fucking
dimension.
And we saw that with edson barboza
versus terry adam.
We've seen these taekwondo techniques
manifest themselves in mmA and you
realize like,
oh,
these are some of the most powerful
things you could do to a person inside a
cage,
but when you see the point fighting
style though,
like the Raymond Daniels or the michael
venom page,
disability ability to blitz if they can
do those other things too.
This is another another level.
There's soMething to it.
So as a fighter,
I wasn't willing to dismiss point
fighting because I had been lied to
already.
I when I went and took taekwondo and
then started kickboxing,
first american kickboxing above the
waist,
first thing I realized was how easy it
was for me to get punched in the face.
I was like,
oh,
okay.
Now if I'm trapped in this ring and I
can't go anywhere and someone's throwing
punches and I don't understand how to
get away from him,
and I'm used to this taekwondo style of
having your hands down low.
I'm getting fucked up.
So I've been lied to.
Talk window is not the best martial art.
Mma.
Yeah,
exactly.
I'm not that.
There is no best push.
There's something absolutely legit about
that blitz,
that karate blitz that some of these
guys can do,
and I fought some really good guys in
those karate style tournaments and I got
an ass made out of me.
I mean,
you,
you don't know what to do and you get
kicked and then the reference point and
the like,
you don't have a chance to fire back
because they're separating you guys.
And I,
I really absorb those lessons.
And I was like in mma,
that ability to close the distance
because every in mma there's so many
guys and connor talked about this.
There's so many guys that have this thai
stance and they're presenting this very
predictable target.
They're standing right in front of each
other.
And I think this stance,
and especially this,
the,
uh,
change,
the forward stance is one of the reasons
why [inaudible] has been caught,
knocked out twice with front kicks
because he squares off veto.
Explain this to me in like,
shit.
Nineteen 97.
When I was tRaining at carlson gracie's,
he was explaining that you know,
some kickboxers are going to have a hard
time in mma even though they're really
good kickboxers because the mma stance,
you really have to square off more.
You can't stand lIke this.
You can't stand in like a boxer and a
kickboxer is a little more open than a
boxer,
but then mma is a little more open than
it was like you almost have to be
square,
but that square leaves you open to front
kicks to the face and then turn turning
side kicks and side kicks to the body.
Think about what [inaudible] has been
dropped with jon jones dropped him with
a side kick to the body.
Um,
soccer.
Robert dropped him with a turning side
kick to the body to fund kick front kick
to the face.
It's because he presents this square
thing,
But to him this is sprawl and throw
punches and throw that they'll like the
blitz had used on vandelay silva.
Yeah.
And it worked much of his career.
He either one with it or lost
with respect that thinking,
but those types of doctrines like is
literally and in martial arts in day to
day life in anything.
If you think anything is the thing,
you're totally wrong because if we all
agree it's nothing.
Then we all acting like it's the thing
that we all start ignoring other things
and those things will work.
So if you have to,
if mma you have to square up.
All of a sudden some guys,
some connor comes out with a different
thing and you were thompson.
The guard is the one that is glaRing to
me right now because,
and I mean I've talked to some of the
smartest and the best and they will and
we do this over and over again and we do
it in everything.
You know,
you Remember when you,
you're,
you cannot cross your feet when you do
an arm bar.
Do you remember that?
Are like,
what the fuck?
What are you talking about?
Head kicks.
Don't work.
And mma like,
you know,
this has been going on forever.
So any absolute decision that this is a
fundamental rule is completely.
That's where you're gonna get fucked.
How about the low calf kick?
Yeah,
I mean the benson henderson was in my
opinion,
the first guy to bring him in and he
started doing that back in the day,
but not at the effectiveness.
The level of effectIveness that we're
seeing now.
That low calf kick his fucking people
up.
That's really interesting and then
they'll adapt and then it won't work,
but that adaptation,
we'll put something else available.
I think the problem with the low calf
kyc is that you really can condition the
lower part of your leg the same way you
can your thighs and I think it's going
to keep working,
but then we have to not get hit by it,
so we'll make a change to not get hit by
him.
Once we do,
that'll force us to do something else
that someone will tAke advantage.
It's amazing how quiCkly it works.
Like if you see a guy get hit with a
Brutal leg kick,
like it takes one or two and then they
start to feel it.
There's something about the first low
calf kick.
You see guys wobbly like that.
That muscle is like really done at the
insertion at the bottom is so small and
it's still taking.
It's taking so much work like it's
carrying so much.
Yeah,
it's,
it's.
These are when things work beautifully
and again,
like I used to take anything we'd talk
about and I'd bring it back to fighting.
Now I tend to take anything in fighting
and I tried to figure out what it means
in life.
Like I've kind of slow over time of
study.
I've started to do that.
Right?
And this is true of this kick and it's
true of anything.
It's like that it works best when the
physiological truth that calf is small
and weak and then works with the
systemic issue.
He's got his foot there and the way he
standing is such that you can hit it to
those two things together,
are making that thing work right now if
you can't change the strength of the
calf.
So the only thing we can change is how
available that calf kick is.
If we don't want to get hit with it.
So we must change that.
And if we do,
we've changed a lot of different things
and now something else is available that
dwayne or duke or somebody else has
already planning how to,
how to take advantage that you've made
that adaptation,
that,
that is for me,
what is eternally fascinating,
but martial arts,
but he can dots,
those are the lessons of life that are
there.
If you can't see that the world around
you has changed dramatically and you act
as if it's the same,
uh,
you get fucked up,
you will get fucked up,
you know,
bring this to paul daily versus john
fitch because that fight was extremely
frustrating to paul daley and frustrated
a lot of people that were watching it
too because john fits was just able to
take him down and kinda do what john
does and hit him on the ground and kind
of beat him up and control the position.
And,
and you know,
at the end of the fight,
paul's yell and boom,
it was so strange,
you know?
And,
but this is a guy that if you just stand
with him,
he's going to fuck you up.
Like if you just decide to trade shots
with paul daily on your feet,
he's got a left hand that is a goddamn
nuclear missile,
you know,
and he basically everybody hits with
that thing goes night night.
It's scary.
Even lorenz larkin,
who's a seasoned striker,
he got clipped by that left hand is
like,
yo,
the ability to make,
generate and create that amount of
impact is elegant.
It's like,
it's like we,
we are human bodies and minds don't do
all that many things that are,
that unbelievably beautiful and rooted
in our history as human beings.
You know what I mean?
This is at the basis of what it was to
survive and protect and expand and
stuff.
And you see it right there.
When paul daley hit somebody like it's
unreal.
The opposite of that scenario is I'm
Johnny Hendricks was fighting Stephen
Thompson and Johnny Hendricks wanted
when stephen would come in,
he wanted to drill him with hooks and
upper cuts and then get to his body and
take him down and do what,
what,
uh,
john fitch did.
But steven's like you doing that.
And after he kicked him and beat him up
at distance and then finish the fight,
johnny was being interviewed and he's
like,
well,
that wasn't my neck and johnny is a
classy guy.
Overall over the length of his career,
he sometimes gets heat.
But who cares?
Right?
Like the opinion of the people shouldn't
matter to Johnny Hendricks.
But johnny said after he said,
well,
I was kinda hoping he'd come in trade a
little more.
It's like,
why the fuck would he do that?
That's not his style.
And that's what you want.
He wants to do what you don't want.
The whole goal is to do something that
benefits him in the scenario and does
not benefit you,
which would be exactly what he did.
Which is why what brings me back to the
paul daley,
john fitch fight like this is the answer
to that style.
The answer to that styles take you down
and not ever let you get up and force
john fitches game on you.
Which is what makes fighting so
interesting.
If john fitch had just decided to go
cowboy and bite down his mouthpiece and
just wing punches.
At paul daily,
until one of them went to sleep,
that would have been a great fight for
paul dalian.
Great childhood.
Um,
when nick diaz,
paul daley did that
mean that was pretty amazing and that
only happens again.
You're creating a moment and it only
happenS because nick was motivated by
who he is in that moment.
He wasn't motivated by stRategy even
necessarily.
He's like,
fuck you,
fuck you.
And,
and,
and that.
However,
people will look at that.
That is again,
it is an expression of the
individuality,
the authentic truth of who nick diaz is.
That's why.
That's art [inaudible] art and fight.
That's a fight.
This was great and he got clipped a
fight.
But this year man,
look at this.
He just,
he just kept the pace.
He's just refusing.
Yeah.
Paul just got too tired too quick.
He was,
he was whinging big shots.
And look at nick just.
Oh,
he got clipped his left hook you're
talking about.
Yeah.
This is over.
Okay.
It's over there.
We're done.
No,
nick won't be done.
Yeah.
Well,
I mean who knows?
Maybe if paul's in better condition,
but this is the end.
The end is nick just gathering him.
It's crazy that he beat his striking
contest,
but he did it with will.
He was always a great boxer.
But I mean,
again,
we're this,
we're this a metaphor for life.
Like you got to one of the greatest
victories ever that that's the
quintessential nick diaz fight to look
at them.
And there are people who don't like him.
Uh,
I love that guy too,
because that what we're,
what we're searching for,
I think is we're trying to be
authentically who we are.
I think that's all we're doing.
That's what nick diaz's,
whatever the fuck you think he is,
he is authentically nick diaz and w.
And the metaphor to me is paul daley is
a wall and you can,
you can dig under it or you can go
around it or you can trick somebody,
gives you a rope or you can climb it or
you can dissemble it.
And nick's like,
fuck it.
I'm going to go through it.
And there are many ways to choose to
live your life and that's how nick diaz
lifts his fucking life.
And that's,
that's beautiful.
What sucks is that he hasn't fought in
forever.
I mean,
he hasn't fought since the anderson
silva fight.
That's crazy.
It's crazy that they suspended him for
marijuana.
When anderson silva tested positive for
steroids in that fight and he got a
shorter suspension.
The nick.
That's a reflection.
That's a cultural leftover cultural
reflection.
That's also that nick refused to pay the
fine because that's nick diaz being
authentically nicholas.
You're not getting that money from me,
but you can admire that.
Like some,
some people will look at that and go do
just pay it.
It'll go this way.
And he's like,
no.
Fundamentally who I am,
I cannot do that.
I will get negative consequences in my
life,
but I will be authentic to who I am.
But nick is like 36 now,
I think.
How old is nick diaz?
No.
Thirty four.
He's 34 now.
So yeah.
Oh dude.
He,
his first fight in ufc,
I believe he was 20 when he fought
Jeremy Jackson like way back in the day.
He was 18,
you
know,
I mean he's been around man,
you know,
he's been a brown so he still like
literally in his physical prime.
And this is crazy considering the fact
that I want to say the anderson silva
fight was three years ago,
somewhere around there.
I would love to see him back in there
again,
you know,
I don't know.
Let me to get what you want to do
though.
I don't know if he really,
truly.
That's what he wants to do.
He'll,
he'll find a way to do it.
And if he doesn't know George George
coming in,
I'm,
I asked george so my at work,
they're like,
hey,
can you see what's up with george and
this nate diaz?
And I'm like,
well ask.
But.
And I'll ask honestly as a friend and ed
and he knows that I'm also employed by
somebody who have a little conversation
but,
but I will never ever sacrifice a
friendship or like a longterm
relationship to like find something out.
I don't cAre about,
and I don't care about twitter,
beef,
sin,
I don't care about the breaking news and
all that,
so it's not inteResting.
It's not anything to do with my life,
but I'll go ask george.
so I asked george who we are friends we
talked yesterday and uh,
we will,
he will tell me the truth and then,
and something as simple as,
oh,
you know,
not as fucking bullshit and maybe not in
exactly those terms,
but he would say,
but when I asked him about it,
he's like,
no bro,
I haven't signed nothing.
And the,
I looked at that and like,
oh my god,
that's george tried to be deceptive.
Like george would normally go ads bs,
man,
that's not happening.
I know I haven't signed anything.
Well I know they've offered him,
but that was george who's shitty at
being deceptive,
trying to be deceptive.
Like he.
Yeah.
So like you said,
they've offered it to.
They've offered it to him and by saying
I haven't signed it means he's
considering it.
I think he's considering it,
but I think he's also considering khabib
[inaudible].
And then there's always the great irish
leprechaun,
you know,
I mean,
I think those are the two big fights.
The two big fights or could be at 1:55
or even one 70 gsp wants to winter of
conor mcgregor versus could be not nate
diaz insider drops bombshell and this is
a May 19th,
saturday.
Oh yeah,
I'm sure he wants that.
But that fight would have to take place
first and who the fuck knows when connor
or be but fight afteRwards,
if it's connor,
it might be a decade later.
I mean,
who the fuck knows who that guy is going
to do now when you give a guy like conor
$100,000,000,
you know what I mean?
This is what happens.
He's throwing dollars at bus windows and
losing his fucking mind and Yeah,
they come out of jamie that ufc inside
of a shop.
Was It?
Yeah,
it was on his podcast.
I did saw that.
I just scrolled down.
Ufc,
brendan,
brendan schaub as you fucking idiots.
Some of secure inside or some.
Well,
I'm sure he does want that,
but if they offer him a fat paycheck and
they really should,
if they want.
Look,
the ufc is in a weird position that they
bought the company for $4,000,000,000.
I don't know what it's worth,
but I would guess it's probably not
really worth $4,000,000,000.
They have a giant monthly,
not it's fucking huge.
The monthly nut that they have to make
caused them to fIre a hundred employees.
I mean there's a lot going on and
there's been some great fights and it's
obviously still incredibly popular,
but you want to make those big pay per
view bucks.
You need the big name stars.
Gsp was always a big name.
Star became even bigger when he came
back and beat bisping and one by finish.
You've got them in a rear naked choke
and put them to sleep.
I mean he's still a giant star.
However,
he hasn't fought in a while,
vacated the title.
It doesn't have the title anymore,
so it's not as big of a deal to the
public size when his sit though.
It is,
it is.
People are dumb as shit,
man.
the funny thing to me is like I always
feel like,
and and I always feel like a lot of
these mechanisms,
title shots,
rankings,
belts,
you know,
twitter,
beef.
They weren't Intended to be there as a
short term solution to give people a
talking point until they saw how till
they got deeply invested and connected.
I think that was,
but yet somehow these sort of extra
outside distractions became the focus.
Who the fuck cares?
Who is the number eight guy and who
cares if these guys are mad at each
other on twitter and the belt itself is
a mechanism for discussion.
What matters is the fight and and I know
that.
It's like,
yeah,
but you're obsessed wIth fighting.
Most people,
if you show them what's really going on
there and contextualize the fact that
these two human beings who have
dedicated their life and taking all of
the knowledge in human history to put on
the line in this moment of of severe
intensity and consequence,
you won't care as much about whether
somebody has an interim title.
You won't know
and it won't and you won't,
but the average joe blow by a paper view
once a year is going to care.
Maybe.
I mean that's the idea behind stripping
tony ferguson.
Yeah,
I mean,
why?
Why,
why,
why takeaways?
Interim title,
let them keep the interim title.
If you want to strip connor,
just strip connor,
strip connor and then tony's obviously
going to go through surgery.
tony didn't do anything wrong.
He fell and hurt himself,
but I think at the root of it is the
filicides isn't incorrect.
Philosophical belief.
So when I,
if I talk to people at the ufc and I
talked to them periodically and I'll
discuss somethinG with them about,
you know,
and it's generally at different times
been like,
hey man,
you can see the work that i'M doing and
you can see people like it.
Could I contribute something x or y?
And then I'll mention,
you know,
they will then say,
well,
you know,
you've got like a really unique way of
approaching it.
We think we got so many casual fans
watching on,
on fox or on these tv stations.
So it's just such a casual audience and
I think about it,
it's like nobody questions at the.
The percentage of people that are a
casual fan that is watching anything is
very close to zero,
very close to zero because the casual,
the not actively choosing what to watch
is being on a netflix search or is
someboDy put something on and I go in
and see what the rock is cooking in this
kitchen.
You Said,
what's your dog's name and the gold dog
marshall.
I go see what fucking joe is feeding
Nobody's watching something.
They're not interested in ever in our
society.
We are all conscious constantly and
consciously choosing what we consume at
all times and if we're sitting there
with our boyfriend or girlfriend or
husband or wife and they're watching it
were somewhere else,
by feeding this nonexistent casual
audience and really believing they exist
despite all the evidence that there is
no such thing,
you are now giving less importance to
the your actual audience who is ready to
go deeper,
ready to see something more meaningful,
ready to be brought somewhere different.
There was no casual audience of almost
anything in our modern world.
I like what you're saying,
but I disagree because people are
watching and they don't know what the
fuck they're watching.
I've done it with people.
I've,
I've unfortunately watch fights over
friends houses before because they
happened to be there and then,
you know,
there'll be people sitting around
watching a why doesn't he just do this?
But they still chose to watch it.
They still may pay attention.
Yeah.
But they made that choice barely paying
attention and they don't know what the
fuck they're watching.
So a guy like you comes in talking about
artistry and all this.
They,
I think you are great.
I love your approach,
but I think your approach in their eyes
is a little bit too esoteric and complex
and maybe it'd be balanced out better
with someone like me.
Yeah.
Yes.
One hundred percent.
And as a result,
we're not over,
especially the last sort of year or so,
I've looked at it like,
you know,
trying to force something like I'm not,
I'm not sort of happily saying that I
would be,
I would be in a relationship with you
and accept what you are.
I'm saying I think we should be in a
relationship only I want to change you.
And that's not right.
That's right.
Yes.
I'm,
I'm literally saying I'm not saying put
a role here.
Tell me what that role you need and I'll
do it.
I'm actually saying I think it should be
different and that's why it's not a good
fit.
And that's why I say a one championship
is a more logical fit for me because
it's younger and it's in its evolution,
but still growing.
I think I agree with you,
but I think it goes back to the money
because I think there's so much money
involved in the use that they have to
make money every month.
I mean it's,
they're in a tricky situation.
It's like,
like if you're a guy and you make 500
bucks a week and you really liked this
car,
god damn.
The core of it is so nice.
I really like it.
Well,
how much is the lease?
The lease is a thousand dollars a month,
but you only make $2,000
a month.
Are you going to do that?
Well,
if I only pay 500 bucks a month in rent,
I can kind of pull it off key.
I guess you can,
but you got to watch every penny and you
got to be cautious and I think you could
put yourself in these traps and then you
have to like really micromanage
everything you do.
Like we've got to make money but we've
got to make money,
but we got to make money instead of we
got to do what we like and put together
what we like and do the best possible
version of what we like.
Like a perfect example is like this
podcast.
I don't have a boss.
There's no overhead.
I don't have.
I mean I have a couple of employees.
It's very easy.
There's no worries.
So I don't give a fuck if I have you on
to talk about stuff or a sleep expert or
I'm not going to have anybody on that.
I don't.
I'm not interested in talking to
because.
And I'll talk about whatever the fuck I
want to.
I don't.
I don't think,
god,
no.
I don't know if people are going to be
interest in this.
I need that advertising money.
I need to say if you.
Because of that.
I think it's one of the reasons why the
show has been successful because it
honestly represents my thinking.
It's like I'm allowed to pursue my
interests and have these conversations
and,
and let it be pure.
I think if the ufc took that exact
approach,
I think the product would be better.
And I think if they had some,
like you breaking down the artistry of
specific techniques,
the air quote casual fan would be more
educated and they would learn more about
it.
I mean,
and you get some of that from dominick
cruz when he does his breakdowns on fox
and some of the other fighters who do
breakdowns.
And when daniel cormier does wrestling
breakdowns,
specific techniques of whY they work and
why they don't work and what someone's
doing right or wrong,
you get educated,
you know,
and I tried to do the best I can to when
it comes to the ground and particularly,
which is where I think is the most
confusing aspect of mma for the casual
fan.
BuT,
um,
I think we should approach the,
the entire sport in the,
the,
the most illuminating way possible.
And I think a guy like you and your
approach is very valuable.
And I love your breakdowns.
Thanks man.
I'm a big fan of them,
so I retweet them all the time.
I just think that you have a very unique
and passionate and it is not just a
passionate approach,
but it's genuine.
My guy.
No you,
I've talked to you when the cameras are
not on and you are just as interested in
this.
I really am.
And I think we're just going through.
Thank you.
By the way,
man.
I think we're going through whatever
you're doing,
if you're trying to seek some kind of
mastery and if you realize you're really
early in it,
you can do it by studying yoga.
Some people do,
some people do it,
they they are in,
they go to church twice a week.
You're just looking to try to grow and
if you do it with something that you're
deeply fascinated and eventually you
kind of learn about connections and all
things,
you know,
it's the study of martial arts or the
study of yoga or the study of jazz or
whatever teaches you about connections
and all things and my life is so good
and these little moments where I'm like,
I don't know why these guys,
I don't work for them.
That doesn't make any sense.
It doesn't make any sense for me to
think that because I get up in the
morning and I sit in my.
I make my wife and I coffee and I sit in
my kitchen and I fucking analyze
fighting.
I sit down and I look at it and I look
for moments and I look for things.
I think people will find fascinating.
I look for things that will teach us
something about life and I look for
these and I make them then what I make
and people seem to like them and then
that gets me jobs commentating where I
fly off and I get to.
I mean I got it so fucking good to try
to square peg my way into a large
corporation because years back I dreamed
about working there.
Sometimes you change your dream.
Sometimes it's okay to change your route
and find the world changes.
Constantly
be afraid to be flexible and you know,
the,
the idea of holding onto a dream for
your entire life despite your interest
is pretty ridiculous.
Yeah.
I mean There's things that I wanted to
do when I was young,
but I don't want to do anymore.
It doesn't,
you know,
you should follow your interest period.
If they change,
you're changing as you change and grow.
I mean these,
like I talked about my waning love or
talk one doe when I realized that it
wasn't really the right way to go.
When I first started doing it,
I thought it was the most effective
martial art.
Once I realized it wasn't.
I lost interest.
I lost interest in competing in it.
I just.
It didn't seem like the thing to do
anymore and I think that as you grow as
a human being,
you're in.
You should have oTher interests.
I mean,
and I think the ones that are the most
intriguing in the most passionate or
you're the,
you're the most passionate of theirs,
they're going to give you the most
reward that if you pursue them,
if you're more passionate about music
than you are about accounting,
but you decide to stick with accounting
because it's what's paying your bills
and like,
man,
that's a dark road.
That's a soul sucking road.
You're going to go,
damn.
It feels scary in.
For somebody in that setting to change.
Just in the short run,
it will be painful,
but in the long run it will be so
valuable and less painful.
Twenty years have way less.
PaIn is such a great trade for two years
of pain,
but if you're that guy with that
corvette that you've got that lease on
and you could barely fucking make those
payments,
you can not take any chances.
You have to just work those extra hours.
Well,
if I just put in two hours of overtime
every day,
that's still only 10 hours of work a
day,
but that was two hours at 20 bucks an
hour and a little out and start doing
those calculations.
And that's how you,
that's how you get fucked and that's how
you get trapped.
And next thIng you know,
you've got a family and you've got kids
and you definitely can't move and you
got a mortgage and you definitely ain't
pursued any music dreams.
Now motherfucker,
it's true.
and this is,
this is the trap that life leads.
Yeah.
You know,
um,
I watched.
So I do a one man show now.
So I belt with a friend.
I built a one man show.
It's like a theater setting,
right?
Like,
it's like,
how do you do that?
Do you use video for now?
It is for,
we put it for punchdrunk ted talks,
right?
So it's four story driven parts of life
that uh,
take you on a bit of an in theory and in
practice so far people seem to be
inspired or find it compelling and
people have cried out of before,
which was really quite moving.
But I people just go to a dog day.
They may be shut,
especially.
Yeah.
Um,
but,
uh,
I,
I did it with,
so I decided I wanted to do that.
I decided I want to get up and tell
stories and hopefully a fun and
entertain people,
find them and inspire them or take them
somewhere.
And I did it partly I watched your show
and then I would have never in a million
years.
So when I saw you in vegas would never
in a million years thought I could do
that because it's clearly a lifetime of
training and development and improvement
and trial and error and thousands and
thousands of repetitions.
And you look at that and you don't look
at an olympic gymnast and say,
I can do that.
And that's kind of.
So I didn't think of it at all,
but then I saw brendan do his show and
it was awesome and I realized he only
started working on this two years ago,
you know what I mean?
And all he represents is hard,
hard work,
sacrifice and drive to learn.
And that's possible.
Yeah.
Which shop is doing is what I said to
him as you are essentially using an
athlete's work ethic and applying it to
an art form.
And that's what's awesome about it.
He's a funny guy who realized like,
I can do standup,
I just need to put the time in and you
know,
I've seen that guy kill kill and he's
been doing comedy for like two years,
you know,
that
is inspiring.
That should,
you should be aware when you see that,
that that means something you work on
for only a couple of years as possible
if you're driven and smart and,
and really committed.
And that's what I took out of his shell.
Plus he explained to me the process.
So I decided I'm doing it right.
So I booked about five months ahead in
winnipeg because there was a ufc in
winnipeg and that's my hometown to do a
small theater and I'm like,
okay,
five months.
And I'm like,
what the fuck do I do?
So I called up a good friend of mine,
greg,
when you booked a,
you have a show.
I didn't have the shell.
Maybe force yourself.
Yeah.
So.
And I cut but I had one plan that was
going to call it my friend graham
isadore who is a playwright and I'm a
writer for vice and a bunch of other
stuff and uh,
and very smart and interesting and we're
good friends but we have very different
perspectives.
And I said I booked this show.
It's in six months.
I need 40 minutes.
It's got to be.
And he's,
he has told some of my stories and vice
before getting drunk with sumo wrestlers
and different,
different stories.
And how much do you weigh?
About 1:56.
And you got drunk with sumo risks was
scary.
It was really like,
it was joyous.
It was.
You've never seen anything like that
became big though.
Yeah.
Oh,
you should see it.
So byamba,
do you know who byamba is?
He's like,
okay,
so if you ever see us sumal on tv that's
beyond.
So he's the guy like in the geico
commercial dot being a figure skater,
tiger woods of sumo wrestling and he is
a genius.
He's a world champion,
but he's also an entertainer.
So he lives in hollywood and he was
very,
very loose here.
Yeah,
yeah.
He Is a sumo wrestler.
Yeah,
there he is.
he is from Mongolia.
But he spends a great deal of time here
working as a television personality and
an actor and whatever,
but he still just look fat.
Oh,
he's got it looks jacked.
Like go to that one where he's doing
that.
Muscle pows that are there.
Yeah.
So that's like those shoulder muscles
through all that fat.
That guy looks like a tank.
Well,
people don't realize,
but underneath there is like you or
underneath eris like tj dillashaw.
You know what I mean?
There is a muscular person underneath
all those additional layers of fat and
flush and skin.
There was,
there's a powerful athlete,
a real benefit and being that fat,
uh,
yeah,
force,
power generation like momentum,
the ability,
I mean if the other guy is that big and
our goal is just to smash into each
other until one of us has taken from the
platform,
you're not that big,
it's going to be very difficult.
Right.
So it's like An arms race of size over
generations where they just got bigger
and bigger out of necessity because if
you're a bigger,
I mean,
what am I going to do?
A,
we could,
in theory,
maybe I could use your size against
your.
I could use technique and strategy and
smarts to,
to take you off,
but I could be big and also to that.
Right?
Right.
So why not v also big.
So it good arms raced to that point and
there are little guys but uh,
but to watch this guy that's with them,
I think he was an impractical jokers.
But yeah,
beyond that it's like he's the most
famous sumo guy in the world and I got
wasted with him at the world combat
games and st petersburg,
Russia.
So I got to commentate it,
right.
So I was in saint petersburg and I
absolutely love,
I found a niche where I get to
commentate like real traditional martial
arts,
a fair bit of done taekwondo and karate
at the pan am games and I did the world
so much championships or the world
combat games.
I do the world championships which is
kung fu and sanda.
And so I've carved out this niche where
I get called for these and,
and develop expertise in these different
areas and get to experience them and see
the little details that change when you
change something.
And so I got to commentate sumo and then
after he seemed to like me and he's kind
of like you would drink,
it must suck that mad.
Like a fizzy drink vodka while you were
in Russia to Russia.
So I love Russia.
I do.
I really do.
I love the russians.
I love that.
Our view of combat and of artists
martial arts and stuff,
they're very straight.
Like you know when you negotiate to
commentate or to do some work that just
straight,
this is what we can pay you.
This is what we expect of you.
If you do that,
we're all going to be happy.
Like it's very sinister story.
Little bullshit.
Frank mir does commentary for them over
there and he's very good.
Frank mir,
I would hope that someone would hire him
in America.
They can't afford them because I was
getting paid way too well in Russia in
Russia.
Really?
No kidding.
You had for him and he said that's why
he couldn't do a deal with bella toi
know and,
and his deal with acb who he loves and
respects and it's become sort of
partners in there with,
uh,
with mr haas,
who runs it,
where frank is now a part partner of the
presentation of it,
went for american shows.
He'll be part,
he'll be part promoter and I think Frank
May even get away from some of the
commentary as much as he's good at it
and loves it.
I thiNk he's interested in some of the
other aspects of it now,
you know.
But uh,
yeah,
they pay very well.
They and they pay the athletes very,
very well.
You can be a guy that had a couple of
ufc fIghts or a belt or fighter to.
They'll give you 60,000
us cash in your hand in an envelope at
the end of it,
you know?
Interesting.
Yeah,
that's great.
Well,
it's always great that fighters have
more options,
you know,
and I know bella tour has become a
viable option to a lot of fighters,
you know,
like guys like ryan bader making good
money over there now and,
and you know,
Roy Mcdonald obviously who's their
champion now.
I just think,
uh,
we need more of those.
You know,
I,
I know that oscar de la hoya is getting
into the mix now,
but just the approach that he's making
seems to me to be ridiculous
old school,
promote us approach,
get some big name and then invest all
your time in that big fight.
But It's,
that's the same thing you were just
talking about the ufc.
The challenge they face now is that we
need another big one.
We need another big one.
It just seems like that,
that approach.
Like we just,
we know,
okay,
if this wasn't the upper,
would this be the ideal approach?
No,
it's never the ideal approach.
The ideal approach is to do the best
fights possible.
The ideal approach is not necessarily to
make the most money or to have the like
the most spectacular.
Like,
like when they were really promoting
ronda rousey and the rematch with or the
fight with Amanda Nunez and didn't
promote nunez at all.
I was,
I,
you know,
I was like,
this is a huge ronda rousey fan.
Everybody knows that too.
Um,
I think she's a,
she's a legend.
I mean what she did for women's mma,
she essentially was the reason why the
ufc decided to have women's mma was one
woman
that woman fighting now I was here that
day.
It just passed her By and it happened so
quick.
But Amanda Nunez,
I was thinking even before holly holm
beater,
Amanda Nunez was the big threat.
I'm like,
that girl could knock you fucking dead
with one punch.
She is such a ruthless striker and she's
a brazilian jujitsu black belt.
I'm like,
this is a terrible matchup for rhonda.
I thought,
yeah,
because rhonda is hands,
although good,
you know,
and getting better and you know,
really we're starting to look like a
polished striker still doesn't have
nearly the kind of power that nunez has
and the that I could nunez nunez is,
she can take it as well as receive it.
We had just seen rhonda sort of have
these bullets moments with like betco
hey,
uh,
you know,
kind of cerebral manner than bricks just
smashed through.
But when You see the overall game like
versus holly holm,
then you got to see all this.
There's a lot oF limitations here and
trying to smash through the bricks if
the bricks aren't there and the bricks
head kick,
you know what I mean?
There's,
there's a lot going on there.
So we're seeing the laYers upon layers
upon layers.
So what happens after you get to the
first layer?
Oh well you don't have a second layer.
Your,
this is your layer,
your layers straightforward.
Move ahead.
And you know,
coaching is to blame as well.
There's a lot of things there,
but the fact that they weren't even
promoting Amanda Nunez,
you have the very first ever openly gay
women's mma champion.
Okay.
There's Interesting aspects and she's
fun girl.
She's interesting and she's a fucking
killer man.
She's a fucking killer,
and they showed it in that fight.
They had an opportunity to make Another
star instead.
They didn't make this other star and
then you look at her most recent paper
view.
I heard the numberS were abysmal.
Bailey,
I heard see if you could find out what
the numbers were because someone told
me,
I think it was shop told me there were
85,000.
That's great.
You should be,
but at this point you have to stop and
wonder is there anything we could do
strategically different like just
because something worked all the way
along in any business or in anything
you're doing,
there might be a time to take a slightly
different approach or to change one of
the fundamental beliefs of how we do
business or something.
You know what I mean?
what you can't do is just go,
well,
hopefully the next one will be good.
I mean you watch that happen all the
time to some massive change in your
business or in life and that change at
first.
People deny that it's there,
right?
They deny and then they say it's a niche
and then they say it's a blip and then
by the time that it's actually in the
heat of something scary or challenging
happening,
you've wasted two or three years that
you could have used adapting to
ready for it.
You know what I mean?
No,
I do know what you mean.
Yeah.
I mean,
I think that what you gotta do when you
have a champion that has spectacular
results like Amanda Nunez,
you've got to hype the shit up or
invest,
hype the shit out of her and that would
have made the ronda rousey fight.
I think even bigger if you show her
smashing misha tate,
you show her,
you know,
smashing Sarah Mcmahon.
You show what she's capable of.
She's a fucking gun
for sure.
For sure.
I know you talked to Mike Brown or
anyone there who's been around the
greats and they talk about it,
but this level now where they are the
brilliance of where what we've seen,
it's another example if you think that
all only fighting to stand up when
you're in guard is right or only keeping
somebody down is the game and the only
thing you have to worry about us,
they'll stand up.
They'll submit you.
Like as soon as you don't recognize
where you are in the change of the river
of life and time,
you sometimes get fucked up and and you
know it's a.
It's a fascinating thing.
I know I literally was just in Singapore
and I just spent days with this company,
but they see the world differently.
They're strategy is simply.
There are.
They're a values based company that
believes in the values of these things
and tries to to show people and share
martial artists reef for the greater
good and it's not some business.
It's what they truly believe.
They truly are going about making
choices.
And when chattery says,
I would not hire conor mcgregor because
he represents,
he's dead,
fucking serious people see represent his
ideas,
his and what he sees.
And I shouldn't speak for him at all.
He's a brilliant man,
by the way,
this guy,
he's a,
he was a homeless kid with,
with a single parent that later became
educated and then move to America and
went to harvard and then started
managing a corporate funds and became a
moitai champion.
And this is all easily documented.
This is who that individual is.
And he's lived that life based on honor,
respect,
you know,
um,
teamwork excellence,
that mind,
that is what built that company.
And one is a billion dollar company now
it's a billion dollar company.
It's in one point 7 billion homes in
asia.
This isn't some mythological idea.
This is a guy who's built a massive
company based around these values.
And that's a different thing.
He's.
But what does he say about common?
Oh,
sorry,
yeah,
I go off on this.
No,
it's cool.
Uh,
so he looks at it as the things that he
says and the way that,
and again,
I shouldn't speak for him,
this was the,
what I've gathered,
throwing things and creating conflict
and controversy as your currency is not
something to be proud of.
It's an interesting way of putting it as
your currency.
Yeah,
I get it.
You know,
and that sounds because,
and I'm not quite all that although I've
drank the koolaid,
I believe in what they're doing and I
see it as real,
not only because my values line up with
it,
but I think they are going to grow
dramatically as a result of some of
these,
the way they see the world,
but not only that,
but I'm still also immersed here and I
like connor,
I think of connor.
I work for tsn because connor fell out
of a march to a red carpet to shake my
hand while the,
my boss was watching.
You know what I mean?
Yeah.
Like the great.
Some of the most interesting moments
I've had are with that guy and some of
the most interesting,
you know,
many dozens of hours of trying to figure
out what's happening in research and
growth has happened by studying that guy
and I see his games that he is willing
to play as part of his strategy for
success as a fighter and success trying
to be successful for his family and his
future.
I see it all connected so I don't
dislike him.
But I respect this,
this idea that conflict and controversy
are not good for us.
I understand that.
But I also understand
psychological warfare and I think the is
a master of that and that has a huge
factor in victory.
I mean,
this is something me and mo musashi use
to his advantage.
Um,
you know,
when you read the book of five rings,
he,
what connor's doing is fucking with
people's heads to the point where they,
he has space in their head and then
conor goes into the cage,
like loose as a goose,
relaxed and calm.
So he's letting you know,
I don't give a fuck about you but you
give a fuck about me and I'm going to
fuck you up right now.
And you're like,
no,
you're not.
You better not.
You can't.
I can't.
This is too much.
And josie all was the perfect example,
although was so out of composure a
although charged at him would that just
leaping left hook and just got fucking
waylaid on the way in.
And eddie alvarez,
The greatest game day performer,
one of the great game day performance
we've ever seen.
and I talked to eddie.
Eddie is one of my favorites and I
admire and am inspired by eddie alvarez,
Michael Chandler tail,
you know,
those two are like the same guy on last
year almost.
But eddie was like,
the plan was to wrestle a lot and stay
at distance and barely at all.
And I stayed at a distance almost the
whole time.
Barely wrestling.
Like he's just like,
it was real like,
and I am by not accepting it was real
coming in and suddenly find yourself in
there and it's real.
And you feel different in your,
you know,
your mind is working differently and
your hormones are working differently
and who you are in that moment is
different and you're like,
holy fuck,
it's real.
Had I prepared for it to be real,
I could be in a different state right
now,
but I denied that this was going to be
real and now it's fucking real.
Santa claus is real.
It's real.
I also think he got clipped early on.
I think that's a factor.
You know,
you get caught on the chin like that and
your legs give out real quick and your
just.
Your brain doesn't work right.
Your body doesn't work right anymore.
I think that's a factor,
the,
the ability that connor has to land
those sharp shots that come out of
nowhere and blitz you and come at you so
fast and just drop those shots on you.
I mean his left hand is a fucking laser
beam and planning it.
That's what that is.
The definition of it.
He's so good at landing that shot and
he's also good at landing a bunch of
other shit too,
man.
I mean,
he pick you apart.
He's a,
he's a real dynamo.
I just,
I hate to see things like what happened
in New York and brooklyn and he threw
the dolly at the bus and smashed the
window.
It's like,
so it's so fucking stupid.
All that thug is shit running in with a
bunch of other guys and everyone's
screaming at will was what would,
it could be due.
He smacked your friend in the face
because your friend was talking shit.
So you know,
I mean,
and even the way smacked him was pretty
gentle,
you know what I mean?
And artem called hIm a coward and he
said,
didn't he doesn't fight.
Conor is a real fighter.
Is like,
listen man,
he's a russian.
your a russian.
You guys got to sort this out on your
own.
That is how they saw it was a pretty
calm sorting out in my opinion.
They didn't stomp him,
they didn't beat his ass.
But once we get to that point,
I mean I get
it.
Yeah,
once you're doing something and I'm
responding,
which he responds.
That happens everyday in gangs and wars
in northern Ireland and Ireland and all
types of religions that's been going on
forever.
Nobody ever wins.
When that happens,
it just goes.
It just perpetuates it and when you
watch it and then there'll be a lot of
people you see this scenario and like
habib's fans or friends or supporters
and condos and they're Like,
he did this,
he did this.
They're both wrong and nobody.
Everybody always,
when soMebody does something bad to
somebody else,
they almost always feel like something
was done bad to them.
Very few people instigate that was
perceived.
Something happened to perceive a slight
and you know,
some people you do one thing to them and
then they're like,
okay,
motherfucker,
now it's to eternity.
Well that doesn't make any sense either.
You know,
you look like a fool,
like,
you know,
you just can't throw a dolly at a bus.
no.
You know,
filled with other fighters because it's
so selfish.
I mean,
all those people that got caught,
you know,
I mean ray bore got cuts in his eyes.
I mean this is the whole thing is a
disaster.
So my theory,
based on bits of information that that
we have,
is that connor,
on some level,
it really,
I mean it reinforces constantly.
If your kid does something terrible that
we know is bad and you gave them candy
every time they're going to give her
candy,
every time she does something that
reward conn has been rewarded.
He gets richer,
more famous,
more influential,
a belts,
and he's been given candy every time
he's done this.
And it works.
And I mean there is parallels in the
political system in America.
There's parallels all oVer the world
that by acting out in these strange
ways,
it's so bizarre and unsettling that
we've rewarded,
you know,
the name for a Band,
candy for bad behavior.
Yeah,
that'd be fun.
But that's what's happening.
Right?
And so now we take it and he's.
And then you add the strategy element
you're talking about,
right?
So he's looking at it and it's like,
okay,
a b would be a great fight.
I'd like to fight in Russia.
He likes challenges is just hard,
but let's do it now.
If I create some viral controversy,
which I did with,
with mala malignaggi,
who is,
have you.
Do you know polly?
I've only talked to him on twitter.
Yeah,
I don't know.
I fucking love polly.
I love them.
I love math and I liked him as a dude.
I really do.
Um,
uh,
but uh,
so he created that and it worked and
it's like,
okay,
whether,
how on what level he's strategizing
this.
He's lIke,
let's go do some pushing and shoving
with habib in his guys.
Some given the finger will be caught on
cameras.
What?
Uh,
what one thing we know about connor,
he's always late,
always late.
He didn't plan to get there when they're
on a bus.
He planned to get there when they're in
the hall,
he planned to get their windows,
a bunch of people around and security
and it's easy to manage little push and
little shove and a couple of cameras and
all of a sudden his $5,000,000
payday,
so $12,000,000
payday in Russia.
And everybody's going crazy.
It'll work.
It's brilliant,
but he's late.
So he shows up there on the bus.
Now the cameras are out and what's he
gonna do?
He's got to perform.
He came there to perform it,
came there to do a thing we showed up
and now it.
Now it goes sideways and that's the most
likely scenario is that it was a,
let's do it.
It'll be.
It'll feel right for us as,
as defending our friend,
but also it'll have some inherent value
in the cameras come out and nobody will
get hurt.
Well,
I think you're probably right there.
It's got to get.
He's got a good point,
but obviously it's a terrible thing to
do and stupid.
You know,
there's,
there's a way to manage that,
but then people say,
well,
you know,
now becomes like the wwe and you know,
there's,
there's people that love real fighting,
that have a real hard time with these
fake wwe style scenarios where you know
that whether it's colby,
covington,
you know,
like he did a promo recently.
We had a,
a girl bY the pool and the girl sat in
his lap and she was like obviously had a
plan script and it seemed kind of corny
people.
There's people who think that's great
and there's people fucking hate it.
I'm the heyday.
Yeah.
I'm the hated too.
I don't know.
I mean,
I don't have a real problem with pro
wrestling.
I joke around about it all the time and
I get the fact that people like it.
I don't like that kind of shit bleeding
into mma.
I think it's dumb
bad.
It's also,
I mean,
again,
if you're viewing it as inspiring
artistry with which there are lessons to
fucking live your life on one hand and
on and that's how I truly see it and
interface with it and experience it and,
and share it and,
and want to see people get to feel that
and then on the other hand you're
putting together these weird scripts to
sell pay per views,
but wrestling,
that stuff that came up in wrestling
because it isn't inherently real needed.
Those extras.
it needed all that stuff.
If we understood how brilliant colbY
covington was,
if we understood how brilliant of a
combat sportsman he was,
he wouldn't have to do that.
But he's doing that and that's what got
him a title shot.
right?
So on the other side,
the other side of the coin,
we're wrong.
You want know if we understood he would
get it based on that,
but we don't understand.
We,
we,
the royal,
we don't get it.
It's like I'll see people talk about
fighting after and they'll be like there
and some people's.
This is their idea of covering a fight
and our fans or people and everybody's
entitled to their own thing,
but they'll be like,
yeah,
the show is kind of a lackluster fair.
Not a lot of finishes.
Fuck in your head.
20 brilliant athletes have interact in
some of your opinion of how it did or
didn't excite you is super valid to you.
But that's not what we were watching.
But what I'm talking about is like what
got them a title shot?
My title shot is being an asshole
because of the reality that we live in.
That's what he had to do.
Right?
Right.
I mean like what he did in Brazil after
he beat damien,
maia said this is a shit hole.
That's literally what got in the title
shot mean if you really stop and think
about it.
He's ranked,
what is he ranked number three?
He's only beaten maya.
I mean he's beaten some other people,
but it terms of top 10 contenders in
terms of like real world class fighters.
There's a lot of guys that are out there
that have fucked up a lot of other
people like wonder wonderboy was like,
how is this guy fighting for the title,
for an interim title and I'm not.
After he's gone through those two big
fights with tyron woodley,
beaten jorge mas,
vidar beaten all these debate and Johnny
Hendricks beaten all these different
fighters.
Colby beat damien maia and that's the
really the big name on his resume and.
But it's also because he's going to be
fighting hartfield oh,
who is a brazilian?
He said a lot of stupid shit about
Brazil.
Brazilians.
Hayden.
Brazil is a giant market.
It's an easy sell and this is.
This is what he's talked himself into
and it's a tough fight.
Don't make no mistake about it.
The guy that beat damien maia is a tough
fucking fighter.
Colby.
Tough.
And again,
you talked to dean thomas or Mike Brown
and they two years back when they were
taught and I would.
I'm a jorge mosfet all freak,
right?
That,
that's one of those special artists to
me.
And so I'll be asking,
you know,
when I'll see mike or dean or these guys
or anybody around that.
I'm like,
hey,
how's,
how's jorge doing?
What's he working on?
What is he changes and they'll talk and
he's always traded with colby.
He's,
he's deadly.
He's one of the greats in the gym.
He,
the two of them are first there last to
leave,
like you've heard about how good he was
under that public surface and I,
but I see what you're saying,
the based on what we've created,
he doesn't have much of a choice if he
wants to achieve his goals other than
doing it this way and the guys who are
good at it,
jail,
obviously the tail is really good at one
of the greatest entertainer.
And don'T you love kale?
I love to fucking love child.
And yet,
this is something I find distasteful
about this art form,
is that game.
Yet somehow child is so lovable.
I love child,
right?
But it's because there's a natural love
of that kind of performance.
And colby and I've,
I've played around with it a little bit
when I played in a band where you would
be rude and arrogant and play that kind
of game.
It's not.
It's hard.
it's hard.
It's hard to do.
It's hard when it's hard to be
convincing.
It's also hard to behave it all the
time.
That's real.
Like you.
You will feel the hatred of all
brazilians who truly hate you even
though you're playing a game.
Getting real about that shit.
Zillions are extremely patriotic,
very nationalistic.
You talk shit about Brazil.
You better duck.
Yeah.
And in fact,
even if you were talk to somebody like a
stereotypical he passionate person we're
talking about here,
and you said it's a joke and they'd be
like,
you can't make that joke.
Right?
Like at their point isn't that I don't
care if he was kidding.
The fact that he was willing to do that
is so disrespectful to all of us that we
must slit his throat and that's what
they'll chant when he goes to walk out
there and they mean it.
They do mean it,
but meanwhile
he just doubled down.
He didn't give a fuck even after get hit
in the head with the boomerang still
doubling down,
swinging for the fences.
What other choice?
I guess.
Well look,
it has got him to the dance and if he
wins two saturdays from this one or one
saturday,
how's it going?
Next?
One is tail and wonderboy.
Yeah,
that's another one to talk.
But if he wins,
if he wins,
he will have a belt.
I mean,
it's not the real belt.
I mean it's an interim belt,
but it guarantees him a shot at the real
belt.
yeah.
No.
so it gets very interesting.
So like I,
I know that I my look at these sort of
systems and the areas around it,
I have a negative bias.
Like,
you know,
it's not about that and I know that's
that's negative to me about the belt or
the rankings or the beefs or whatever,
but the belt cannot mean what it meant
before.
By the nature of once upon a time there
were only ever 27 of them and now there
has been 340 of them.
By nature it cannot be as valuable as it
once was and when there's two in yours,
it inherently cannot have the value
because scarcity is where value comes
from.
Yeah.
It's really just a promotional tool.
It's a marketing tool and it's a.
It's a questionable one.
You know,
there's,
there's a real good argument that it's a
bad idea to have these interim title
shots because you know,
like,
okay,
well what's the rules?
You just decide when to have an interim
shot,
especially with a guy like tony
ferguson,
right?
He beats Kevin Lee spectacular five
triangles and off to nobody after that
last one.
One the interim title,
and then you strip it because he falls
down during a promotion.
He trips on some wires.
I mean,
this isn't,
it's not like he went and did something
stupid outside of fighting.
He was just doing promotion and tripped
on some wires,
so freak accident and that really,
if we move away all other things and
just look at the systems at play and how
and why it's there.
If he was,
if he had another 2 million instagram
followers,
that would not happen.
You're right.
And that's it.
It's strictly that.
That is true,
right?
Yeah.
It was a giant,
huge star.
There's no way they would strip him.
No.
Yeah,
no.
And,
but by not being,
because he's a character,
he's,
he's an oddball.
He is a unique.
He's one of a kind.
We should celebrate that.
He's an individual.
He's different than everybody that's a
sale.
If you're going to strip connor,
which they did,
and you have khabib fight for the title,
the true title and,
you know,
look,
that's arguable whether or not you
should do that as you'd probably be two
interim fights are transgender,
um,
titles,
which will be cool.
He's not beating the champion if he
didn't beat the champion,
he beat out quinta.
How is him beating out?
I quinta more valid than tony beating
Kevin Lee.
That's crazy.
It isn't.
It's crazy.
It doesn't make any sense.
I mean,
not taking anything away against albert.
Al took that fight on unfucking one
day's notice.
Yeah.
So it's even more ridiculous and
awesome.
yeah,
and that was a great fight too.
It was
really fun.
Yeah.
Well there's,
there's a puncher.
Yeah.
It was really fun and I like la quinta
is another one of these guys.
How can you not be inspired seeing a guy
like life is traveling along and all of
a sudden you have this one shot at
something.
You're not ready.
You're don't have.
You haven't prepared in the ways you
want,
but you know what I'm going to go for.
That's a life lesson.
And there's also like I.
There's a forgiving nature to this
machine that is kind of admirable.
Like alice created problems.
Al has had conflict with that company
and then they were still like,
you know what?
Let's do this.
Did it though.
They did it because they wouldn't,
they wouldn't use paul felder the
fucking athletic commission.
That's ridiculous.
Ridiculous.
I mean all their wisdom,
they decided that paul felder isn't
ranked high enough like who
you don't know shit.
Don't even know where rankings come
from,
which is a bunch of people like hanging
out who kind of watched,
fighting a bunch of,
making an arbitrary choice and then
combining it like,
do you know what,
um,
what a first class noticer is?
Have you ever heard this term?
So a first class noticer in business or
any number of things.
as somebody who over times you start to
see the different systems and how they
interact with each other and you are
one,
you clearly are a first class noticer,
you see big picture,
small picture combined.
How the outside right now you're like,
well,
the,
the commission did this,
but paul felter did that.
Rankings are this way and you're able to
pull all these things together and look
at it.
Right?
And if you look at any of these things
from that perspectiVe of how the systems
all work,
the whole thing barely makes sense.
You know what I mean?
Paul felder is brilliant if it needs a
dangerous one,
55,
including khabib and committed and
mentally strong and a striver
world class striker and his striking his
fucking deadly and he's not just a
striker in terms of punching like al.
He's a really nasty kicker.
I now can kick.
Yeah,
no doubt about it.
But paul was a bit more achieved in,
in his,
uh,
he's got more weapons,
more complex,
spinning back fists and elbows and knees
and nasty leg kicks and you know,
went three hard rounds with barboza.
Went toe to toe with them.
I mean,
he's that good.
He's that good on it
and smart he is.
He's a great analyst for such a young
one.
But when you look,
so you're like,
how is that possible?
Because that's really hard and it's a
different skill set than just being a
good fighter.
This language and being able to
rationalize things and all,
all these different things.
But you look back and he did it on the
small leaks,
which he didn't need to do.
He pursued because it was of interest to
him.
He pursued it to get good at it because
he loved it,
which means he's predisposed to thinking
that way.
So now you also have a thinker,
a fighter,
incredibly dangerous striker,
a guy who can play complex games in it,
and you in your infinite wisdom,
don't think he can fight habib because
somebody somewhere said that he put a
seven next to his name instead of a
three
real real problems with the athletic
commission and we won't go into depth.
I don't want to cause any problems.
But uh,
they,
they had some real issues.
they're young,
they're new.
Yeah.
there's a lot of nonsense that was going
on behind the scenes.
But I think that what was interesting
about that fight was we got to see al
step up.
We got to see khabib have some issues
with striking and you know,
we got to see.
I mean,
what,
what I don't like about it is this whole
the whole championship thing.
What I don't like about this,
he didn't beat the champion to become a
champion.
They just sort of like set this,
fight up our.
And preparing for that fight,
he was preparing for a three round fight
and then tony gets stripped all those
things.
Yeah.
It.
because they don't make any sense.
Yeah.
They don't really make any sense because
if we go back to the.
if we have some kind of value root of
what we're about other than the
necessity to to sell things based on the
same marketing that we used,
we wouldn't have to be in that
situation,
but we find ourselves there and when
you're on,
when you're on the bottom of half guard,
you just have to work your way on a half
guard and that's what that machine has
to do.
And that's what habib has to do.
And that's got an artificial standup.
yeah,
exactly.
Exactly.
Got stood up.
Yeah.
I dunno.
Wonderboy until man,
that's a big fire.
That's this saturday.
That's fucking.
That's chaos stuff.
Fight is very interesting to me.
I am very,
very,
very interested in that fight.
Me too.
Yeah.
I want to see what happens when till
fights.
Wonderboy,
because I was stunned by how easily till
ran through cowboy and cowboy in all
fairness is not,
in my opinion,
a real one 70.
He's a tweener.
I think cowboy would be a one 65,
you know,
and I think maybe his struggles to make
1:55
maybe you should be 10 pounds heavier
and I think that 10 pound weight class
thing is real.
I think that's where it should be every
10 pounds.
Darren till is a fucking huge guy.
So steve,
yeah,
they're both very tall and strong,
but till you know,
gregory's well over 100.
Well over 200 pounds.
He's walking around like um,
you know,
fucking two.
Oh,
five and shit.
And cutting down to one 70.
It's a good one man.
Yeah,
it's a really,
you know,
there's so many little odd ball
variables and unknowns,
right?
Like we literally when we go and we look
at these,
the more you've studied and analyzed and
commutative fighting for 20 years of
your life,
the more you realize how little we
actually know,
like we have about two or seven or 18
percent of the actual information.
You know what I mean,
and we're trying to work with it and the
big one.
So when,
when cody fought tgr,
I'm dominic,
I was like,
I just don't see how he can win.
I don't see how cody can win.
And then somebody say,
well,
why'd he say that?
He knocked out all these guys.
I'm like,
well yeah,
it's hard to get to dominic and we've
never seen evidence of him doing well
after those minutes.
The evidence isn't there to see it.
Of course 100 percent wrong but there.
But you have to go by what evidence you
have,
what have we seen or what information
that we gathered that can allow us to
make this decision to me.
Cody garbrandt did not have.
There was no evidence he can be dominant
and then boom,
he beats up dominic and you're blown
away.
And that's an exciting feeling.
And that is,
I think what's at play here.
Is there any evidence that that darren
till can do what rory macdonald couldn't
do and jorge mass fidel couldn't do and
get to a guy who has that movement,
that blitz thinking that karate's a,
those karate instincts we were talking
about.
We've seen no real evidence of that,
but that doesn't mean he can't do it.
It doesn't mean he can't do it,
but the evidence isn't there.
I don't know about that.
I was stunned by his ability to close
the distance on cowboy,
that nasty left elbow that he learned it
over the top.
The way he put them away.
I don't know.
I think that's pretty good evidence that
he's a fucking monster.
I agree.
And his fights previous in the ufc as
well,
although they didn't have a lot of
fanfare behind them.
Stunning results.
And then you talked to people that know
him,
you know,
talk to people that know his striking
aquaman and people that have seen him in
the gym and understand what he's been
through in his life.
And he's a young guy.
I thInk he's only 25.
How old darren till?
I'm pretty sure he's 25.
Celso,
never lost,
never so fuckIng pissed man.
Yeah,
and then you see the pictures.
Even that 25 years old.
That's wild man and but what I'm saying
is I would have,
I would not be the slightest bit
surprised if he could do it because
we've seen enough over time to know that
what a 23 year old is capable of,
they'll see the whole game differently.
They'll see their understanding of where
they are in relation to the other guy is
so different that it just on one day,
all of a sudden all of these 25 year
olds are just so fucking good and we
don't really have the language to
explain why.
You know,
can we just say,
oh,
he was able to close the distance on
Stephen Thompson.
IF he does will say yes,
but then the question will be how when
nobody else could do it,
how and why could he do it?
And that's always what obsesses me.
If you see him do it,
there is now the explanation isn't he
was better at closing the distance or
his range management was excellent dot.
That's true for a bit.
But then my next question,
the next morning will be like,
how the fuck did he do it?
What?
What changed now?
What about the entirety of the game
itself?
The systems of the relationships have
two fighters.
What changed in such a way because of
his behavior and that's where it gets to
me really,
really wild because right now nobody
gets to Stephen Thompson and I mean
nobody really at all.
Tyrone is knocked down twice about them
really badly.
Just 50 minutes,
15 minutes.
The fight.
Those are the moments in the fight where
they engaged.
See,
the problem with those two tyron woodley
fights is what they fought
wonderboy the right way.
That's how you got to fIght them.
You don't engage and when you do engage,
you got to be absolutely convinced
you're going to land.
And tyron did and did land and hurt
them.
I mean you looked at those two fights.
Tyron is the one who's the wrestler,
but he's also the one that hurt
wonderboy.
Wonderboy never heard tyron and those
fights.
Nope.
Tyron had him very close to being out.
and I just wonder if wonderboy is
starting to slip,
you know,
you've got to wonder,
you gotta wonder if all his years of
combat sports,
all of his years of kickboxing.
I mean you to remember this guy is one
of the most spectacular kickboxing
records ever.
I mean,
what is it like $57 or something like
that?
Kickboxing.
And then he gets into mma and you know,
he loses to matt brown,
he gets kind of beat up on the ground,
comes back,
has some really good fights and you
know,
it's been in there with world class
fighters and beaten some world class
fighters.
But he's also,
I want to say he's 34,
and that was a lot of fights.
although we didn't get until recently
until those three examples,
he ever really get hit all that much.
But it's still the where Stephen
Thompson
find out how wonderful is.
That might even be thirtY five.
Yeah.
The hips and the knees and the shoulders
and that whole 5:35.
But.
And there's also that what he.
I mean he developed mastery in what he
does.
And once you've developed that elite,
elite top level of reached your highest
potential,
it's hard to keep going.
And then the masses start to close that
distance though the,
the general young kid start,
you know,
a kid at tristar,
like some of the young guys,
they have that and they've had thompson
in there for years and for us has been
able to study people like that up close
and they all studied leonardo.
Now the young guy can do a lot of those
things at a much higher level than
fighters that came before them.
So your level of mastery starts,
you plateau to a point that it's hard to
go beyond.
It's really hard work and sometimes it
requires you to get a little shittier
for a bit too to go past that plateau to
weaken or get worse by having to
reexamine what you believe and the way
that you train or the way that you fight
to break through a plateau.
You've got to kind of be willing to go
backwards a bit.
And when you're fighting tyron woodley's
of the world,
you cannot go backwards.
So it's kind of kind of stalls you
there.
So,
but ultimately the big question also is,
is there some other strategy that hasn't
yet been done that is a Stephen Thompson
beater and that loW leg kick you talked
about may so I cannot get to you.
So what would I prefer when I'm fighting
Stephen Thompson body lock,
if I can get to the body lock cover up
and down to get to a body.
Like I got to touch him,
that's really hard.
He stops me from doIng that or I got to
hit them or kick them.
But when I do that he moves away and
hits.
What if I can just get to the edge of
his sort of bubble of,
of,
of hot,
that hot range where he can hurt you and
maybe that low leg kick is a part of
that.
Maybe that low leg kick,
just getting on the outside of it where
you're still somewhat safe,
but you can smash him up a little bit.
Maybe those with a weapon that hasn't
been used.
Well it's.
This is also arguably the best striker
that wonder boys ever faced in mma.
Arguably right,
I mean moskva dolls,
very talented striker as well,
but wonderboy is a master of that front
leg in that front leg is a real tricky
one because that karate style that he
uses,
he keeps his hands down low.
He stands totally sideways on you and
you've got to get past that front leg
side kick and johnny couldn't get past
it.
hendrix got lit up by that front leg,
side kick and then front roundhouse kick
to the face right afterwards.
It's just there's a lot going on with
that front leg if you're not used to
that,
and then if you.
If you get too obsessed with it,
the backlash comes.
Yeah,
till is a way better way better.
Master of distance.
He understands distance and straight and
he knows how to close that distance with
explosive power.
Very interesting.
Just before he fought cowboy,
his successes were fighting at distance
and smashing guys who came in,
so he does do that.
He does.
By doing it,
you understand it on a different level.
You connect to it.
It is tie way,
whereas wonderboy doesn't across way and
wonderboy is fantastic at moving his
waist back and forth like a snake and
jumped on it.
He's really good at that too.
Yes.
Tony ferguson's really fucking good at
that.
Yeah.
And that.
So when I get to go study sunda and kung
fu and woo shu,
there are some of my friends are like,
well,
you know,
like enjoy it.
I'm like,
nah,
there's going to be some brilliant shit
to learn over here.
This and some of that long fist stuff
like people will often say,
well kung fu is not super relevant.
Some of that long fist reaching where I
move my body through space to reach you,
which people would say is dangerous.
You get countered while I check the
answer is don't get countered.
The answer isn't discard a valuable
weapons and so you see some of that.
Tony does that stuff really,
really,
really a lot of really cool.
He does some work with the.
That's cool man.
Yeah.
He doesn't love roast wing chung too.
When I'm sitting in your guard wanting
to beat you up,
tell me that.
Isn't wing chung just were attached.
That's what that is.
That's what that is,
right?
I mean there's techniques in every
single art that are established.
Realistic art that are valuable,
you know,
and there's,
there's gotta be something in wing chung
the people are missing for sure.
For sure.
Sarah,
I mean art like that.
People would look at and mike discard
because they would think they're limited
to only this scenario.
Well that scenario happens.
I'm in your garden,
I want to fight.
We are.
That's that scenario.
So that thing may not be useful to
fight,
you know,
frank mir.
But that thing will be useful in a
context when you're fighting.
Well,
how about jon jones is use of you grab
his wrist and he comes over the top of
the elbow that is hand tramping.
Yeah,
for sure.
I mean it really is what it is.
Or when he leveraged his sherif oh yeah,
that's limb structure.
That's old school structure.
How and
why that hasn't been rabid hall a lot
more.
Although you do start to see that that
moment where were,
you know,
I get to all four,
I get to four points that I'm going to
stand up and you just kind of decide,
okay,
that's all right.
We'll get back to the fence in that
process of standing up.
A loT of guys throw a fight finishing
kick there or just at least take that
chance to smash your leg with one.
Like if there's free shots that exist in
these moments and jon jones is a master
of finding them.
It really is.
Yeah.
I hope they figure out what the fuck
they're going to do with him soon.
I don't know where they stand now in
terms of his suspension or what have
you,
but here's my ultimate goal,
my hope,
my dream is that cormier fight for the
heavyweight title and somewhere around
then they announced when jon jones,
the suspension is up,
they announced John Jones versus brock
lesnar.
Love it.
I love that.
I just,
I mean,
look at their body types and look at
what they are and whether they come
from.
I mean,
I love it,
but I know you've sat down with john and
stuff,
but what did you like?
What did he feel like?
You know what I mean?
Like what?
What reed did you get from him?
Did you feel like he was saying the
things that he thought you wanted to
hear or did you feel he was being honest
and genuine?
Definitely both being honest and he's
also had some things that he planned
out.
I like john a lot.
I really love that guy,
but I think he surrounds himself with a
bunch of knuckleheads.
I Think he's,
he's around too many people that are a
bad influence and I think he's,
he's a wild man and I think when he's a
wild man around other people that are
sort of indulging that stuff with them.
This is the word that I get,
not just from what I know,
but from the people that know him very
well is that he just around the wrong
people.
You know,
he's got bad influences and I mean if
you can identify that then you must
change it.
Yeah,
it's not,
it's not to take any personal
responsibility away from him either
because I'm sure he also makes for a bad
influence to them.
Know the fucking baddest man on the
planet can live like this.
I'll live like this to fuck it.
Let's do more coke and know let's party
harder.
Let's drive fast.
Let's go drunk.
Um,
I don't know,
you know,
I don't know what the answer is.
We're a guy like john,
you know,
I really don't know.
I mean it's a,
he's got to have that come to jesus
moment.
Yeah.
Or not.
You know,
maybe he just keeps doing what he's
doing and keeps beating everybody's ass
and people keep forgiving them and
hopefully it doesn't wind up in jail.
BuT you should for sure get a driver,
you know,
for sure.
Get someone to fucking driving around.
That's a bad.
that's a good band aid,
but it's not going to be the problem
solver.
Yeah.
The truth is I think,
I mean we get to live the life that we
want,
like we get to choose the things that we
do,
like we have free to a certain extent to
a certain extent.
I know free will is something that's
been discussed and it's a fascinating
concept,
but to some degree,
you know,
we are offering our own lives,
and if it isn't going the way that you
want it,
small tiny changes can push it a
different way.
Yeah.
It's a matter of whether or not he's
willing to make those changes.
And you know,
right now I'm sure he just wants to get
his license back,
you know,
but like when I see him like having
these battles back and forth with chuck
ladell online,
like bark away from that.
Like chuck liddell's and old warrior
who's clearly taken too many shots like
and you know,
this calling him an old man and saying
all this stuff and it's like just be the
better man and this situation.
You're,
you're the top of the heap right now at
the top of your game.
You don't want some young guy doIng this
to you 15 years from now talking to you
that way.
I mean this is,
these are the dark days,
but when we turn the tv on,
I don't care if you watch cnn or fox or
cnbc or whatever or the nfl or hockey or
fighting or whatever.
A lot of what we see is a bunch of heads
who somebody has said you choose
different sides or they know that's what
they should do and then they just argue,
yeah,
we watch it.
We're taught it.
We see it every single day,
all the time.
Crazy.
It drives me crazy and fighting the
sports guy talk I.
That drives me nuts when it comes to
fighting because they have this sort of
robotic predetermined pattern of
behavior that they apply to football and
baseball and and I just feel like
fighting is more personal,
more intimate.
There's more on the line.
There's more at stake.
It means more to me and when I see that
dopey sports guide jock talk applied to
fighting,
it makes me angry.
It makes me angry too,
but it for for different reasons as
well.
One is this,
this doesn't apply exactly as you said,
and the other one is the city of and
apply to football or anything because
it's ritualistic like it act as if the
show doesn't exist,
if that's the reason it looks.
So we were talkIng about how things
meanings change once upon a time.
That was a professional speaker.
Now that is a rehearsed over,
strategized,
constructed artificial speaker and in a
world where someone watches the fucking
joe rogan podcast or goes on and sees
dwayne training guys or watches a
supermodel on instagram or sees what the
rock has cooking.
Like I said,
we see real people everywhere,
so now this becomes ritualistic and
artificial.
It's a strip club dj to hey,
come into the top stage.
It's like that predetermined sort of
pattern of behavior.
The they adopt this pattern and you know
there's a lot of people that adopt that
sports guy pattern and there's a lot of
shitty writers that do it too.
They apply that insulting style of
Writing to combat sports and some of
them have never been inside a cage and
the fucking life and apparel even
trained.
Yeah,
no it,
it's,
if you,
if you have not been kicked
in the fucking head in front of your
mother,
you have no right to criticize me.
Fight my fucking god.
Oh god.
I got.
I wouldn't want that pressure.
So a couple of punches happening and I
get caught in a guillotine and I'm
thinking I'm okay and I'm driving my
shoulder in and then I start to go out
and I'm just.
And I kind of hit them in the tap and I
look up and my mom is right fucking
there.
She's right there.
and my mom,
my family is wonderful,
right?
Like I got the best wife that humans
have ever had in my parents and her
parents.
I'm surrounded by great people and I
know that my mother literally was
looking at me like,
I'm proud of you.
You know,
don't worry,
this happens,
but my memory has her going,
well,
she's probably just sad.
Sure.
She's gonna shake shaker here.
Yes,
it was.
Yeah.
But if you haven't been through that,
if you haven't experienced failure,
if you haven't been carried out on a
stretcher,
whereas everybody booze you or felt
victory or been terrifying,
you cannot logically criticize them
because you don't understand the thIng.
If you haven't done it,
if you have some respect for it,
I'll respect you.
Just just understand what they're going
through.
Like I don't think you necessarily have
to have gone to war to be a war
correspondent,
to understand it,
to talk about it.
You don't have to have shot someone to
be able to understand what people are
going through or at least try to
comprehend it,
but have some respect about it.
There's a way to criticize technique and
movement without being insulting.
And I think this is a part of the
problem with this.
The sports guy attitude isn't insulting
attitude.
It's a judgmental one that's judgmental
and mocking and I think they played
johnny lunchbox.
I think they play to dumb dumbs and I
just.
It really hurts my feelings when I see
that sort of strategy applied to
covering mixed martial arts.
Yeah,
and like I said,
it acts as if as less and less people
consume this older but valid interface
television,
less and less and more and more are
consuming other things that are
different and new and and stuff.
It's bizarre that the old one starts to
say,
yeah,
well we still do it this way.
Right?
You can't do it that way because people
now it looks weird and old now it looks
as context has changed because we have
seen thousands.
We've seen Michael Chandler eight today
and how he held his son and this guy is
saying,
well,
you know,
the striker versus grappler like,
and it's just.
They haven't evolved.
They,
yeah,
you have to step in and this applies to
us all.
You have to step in and look at where
you are and what it's meaning is and
realize,
oh,
technology changed.
The audience changed.
The world changed.
My life changed.
The economy,
changed the market.
All of these things have changed.
I'm still the same.
I've met.
I'm a dinosaur.
That doesn't make sense.
I can't do that.
I must change,
but the reason sports,
television,
the nfl or
many of these things,
news doesn't is it starts out that there
are innovators,
so in fighting it was dana white and the
fertittas and you guys and this vital
young innovative creators and then as it
grows,
you need organized thinkers.
You need people who can organize and
structure something so that can grow.
The problem is they get really good at
structuring hierarchies to get really
good at structuring business in such a
way that they are then in charge and
then when it changes,
you need those creatives again,
but the but these structure guys are
there and they've built these formulas
that they are then bound by where it's
like,
well,
of course we're going starting with the
opening shot and then we're gonna go.
We're right here in Brazil,
shot of christ the redeemer,
and then we'll go and here we've got an
unbelievable matchup with the winner
gets a title shot.
Those are rituals was a bizarre
formulaic rituals created when they
mattered and that we're valuable by
highly intelligent people that that,
that,
that we're required to make this work.
But now you meet different people,
you need a different thought,
you need crude the creatives back in and
they usually don't want that.
Yeah.
I think I like your point about
different approaches and I think one of
the best ways to maybe perhaps have a
different approach is to have more
intense coverage of training footage.
Great.
You know,
and I think they're doing that with the
embedded series of those online things.
I'd like more people to check those out.
I think if more people got an
understanding of how much is involved in
this,
like when people get injured and pull
out a fight,
it's like some people will freak out and
complained and write a bunch of stupid
shit.
Like I don't know what happened to mirko
cro cop,
but you can't say anything bad about him
because he's a superhero.
The guy,
if that guy pulls out of a fight,
you got to go,
well,
he obviously must be too hurt to fight
and this is part of the game,
you know,
I mean,
but I've read some ridiculous shit that
people have said about mirko online.
Like I went to canelo's page the other
day,
oh my god,
this pictures of canelo alvarez and
people are judging his body and st
luke's tiny now and there's all these
emojis of pills and needles all
throughout his entire instagram post is
fucking.
The comments are ruthless.
Just ruthlessly fucking insult
thing.
I mean this is just the world we live
in.
It is.
I did a breakdown on vito and like you
know,
he'd go and instagram is,
at least in my experience,
is the least negative because it's the
newest.
What's the most negatively youtube.
I agree.
Yeah.
Probably because it's the oldest,
right?
It's these elements because as things
get older,
a lot of negativity is a random
positive.
People leave positive.
People leave because they go on there on
the early part of the technological
adoption lifecycle.
Positive people are innovators and early
adopters and they go onto the newer
thing and then you leave behind the
people who are negative and made the
whole place go septic and then they
argued with each other.
I wonder.
I wonder if that's the case I want.
I've never figured out
what is wrong with youtube comments,
but there are so ruthless like whenever
I have a liberal woman on in particular
who you have on with an open mind and
are interested in their perspective.
Some of them are my friends like abby
martin when she's on.
I don't even fucking touch those comms
or whitney when whitney cummings is on.
I don't look at the comments period
period.
But if I did those would be the last
ones that I would because they've looked
at them before and like whitney contract
with me and she's like,
what
the fuck?
And I was like,
don't read that shit.
It's like don't taste the poison that
wherever the positive people are,
if you're going to spend time.
And I liked to because if 50,000
people watched me do a break down,
that means a lot to me and if 60 of them
commented,
I'm going to.
If I can schedule in the day 45 minutes,
I'm going to take the time and think as
many of them as I can,
but only where the goodwill.
I only where the positive ones are,
not that I want to be reinforced that
what I'm doing,
but I'm not going to spend the time on
people who are going through life so
negative that I can't get through to
them anyways.
Somebody who's going through life
looking for something and trying to to
either be inspired or learn something or
by positive.
Those are the people that you should
spend time with and it's also like the
reverse of giving candy to your kid when
they're bad.
Don't go give those people candy when
they're negative.
You want them to get away from that.
You want their lives to get better,
which it will if they stop having that
behavior.
Yeah,
maybe of
them are just so broken,
but it's just like their structure is so
poor.
The structure of their thinking is so
poor and you know,
all a lot of them are shut ins and
there's a lot of people with mental
illness that are just constantly
commenting.
I mean,
and then there's the argument to kill
the comments,
but then people get furious at you.
We had an issue for a while and it was
an accidental issue and the issue was
during the stream we don't allow the
live chat because it was always like con
to your mother's a like our shit because
people were just trying to get
attention.
If we read that stream while we were
doing the show,
the show would be inexorably altered,
you know,
you would you would.
You'd be altered by like what?
What?
What are you saying?
Don't say that like you would read it
and then that would be the show.
The show would be these people as well.
It's just not necessary or valuable
because of the fact that we had the
comments killed during the live feed.
You couldn't.
You couldn't chat during the live feed.
When we would transfer it over to
youtube,
the comments would be disabled and
people went crazy and I had a tweet
about it,
but look,
I'm not disabling the comments.
I don't know what this glitches,
but they're going to figure it out.
But she decided to disable his comments
on purpose and do they fucking went
crazy and they were attacking him.
But what are the numbers that give a
shit like who?
Have you ever commented a youtube video?
Have
you ever watched a youtube video and
commented on it?
I don't think I ever have.
I never have either.
I don't know anybody worth a fuck that
has that.
That's part of the problem is like I
know there's some really positive
comments and people who are healthy.
People were just interested in debate
and discussion about particular topics,
but when you're dealing with all these
negative people,
like what are the numbers?
If you have a million people watching a
youtube video or are we talking about a
100 people?
Is it even.
I don't even think it's.
It might not even be 100.
You might be dealing with like 30
cousins and they're the ones that are
going to be mad that you disable the
comments,
but is that really matter?
And it is keeping the,
that cesspool open,
keeping that commode open for them to
dump their fucking verbal diarrhea into.
Is that really feeding the bay?
Is that giving the kid candy for being
an asshole?
Is it the same
that maybe maybe I went,
saw you a stand and talk to 600 people
who came to a show.
You had an in depth conversation,
chem trails this and fucking fighting
that with each of them in the eye.
You spent for sure four hours when you
took a bunch of friends out for dinner
and invited me,
which was really cool by the way.
Thank you.
I brag about it,
all of that.
Uh,
and then I saw you walk across.
That was four hours for sure.
Okay.
Two to four hours.
I don't know the exact number.
Then I see a walk across the casino and
in that time you do it again for another
half hour as you know joey diaz.
Oh,
you know.
And then we sit down and somebody comes
over.
As soon as you sit down and they say,
hey,
can I go fuck off man,
I'm meeting.
That's the guy who will tell the world,
joe rogan's an asshole.
That guy say,
fuck off.
Come on man.
I'm whenever I can't.
You can't just stop your meal.
Every time someone comes over 200 inter,
like human deep interactions,
meaningful interactions,
that one can fuck off.
Well,
I don't want to say fuck off.
I just think that people have this
distorted idea of space that they should
just be able to invade your space while
you literally have a mouthful of food.
Yeah,
and I mean,
I've had it happen.
I've had.
It happened when I was feeding my
daughter.
Have her in my lap.
He'll go get a selfie and you definitely
can't get a selfie right now while I'm
feeding my daughter.
Get the fuck outta here,
man.
That's a misunderstanding of,
of space.
Yeah,
there it is.
A strange thing.
I mean,
I didn't watch my wife was asking me
because I was in Singapore.
If I watched the um,
the royal wedding,
I'm like,
nah,
fuck to stand out at all.
I don't understand the motivation for
doing it.
I,
I don't even want to get it through.
But those are still humans.
Like those are still people.
People don't understand that woman shit.
She thought so this way here.
You know what I mean?
There are people.
And can you imagine if the person who
asks you why you're feeding your
daughter?
Somebody did that for maybe the first
time.
He'd be like,
well,
I can't believe it's good.
Wants to selfie with me.
But after that it will be.
You're still living your human life.
Yeah.
I'm the only one you have just can't
interrupt
people while they're sitting at dinner
with their family or with their friends.
They're sitting there cutting food up.
It's just like they don't owe you that.
Like can.
You shouldn't ask for that.
It's just not the way to do it.
It's just not.
And you gotta know when people can't
stop,
they just can't just say hi.
Can you just say hi?
No one can say hi.
Everybody wants to dress up their
facebook.
Everyone needs that fucking selfie.
It's just like we're.
We're in a weird space with that stuff
that,
that whole social media shit.
Because people want something from you
that they get up.
It's not just they're a fan and they
want to say hi.
They want something from you to make
them look cooler.
That.
And it's like you,
you can give them some currency.
It's like you're a pokemon and they can
pick you up and
get a point for.
It's weird.
Really weird.
So I told you,
I was saying,
oh shit for breezy over doom got flat
and he was just going to fight in
Russia,
I think against all neck.
Yeah.
Well that's not happening.
That's a wrap.
That's a wrap on that.
Well,
he's 40 years old.
I'm trying to compete in something
that's a young man's game.
That's the thing.
It's like you can get mad,
you can get outraged and that's a
reasonable result,
a reasonable response if you want.
But if you rationalize,
if you have empathy,
it's like this guy still wants to do
this thing that his body won't allow
them to do.
And so he's willing to bend the rules to
attempt it.
He failed and now he's going to have to
pay the.
Yeah,
it's a month after his knock out last
volkov right?
Volkov fuck yeah.
Dangerous guys.
Fucking dangerous.
Big,
long,
tall knockout artists.
The heavyweight thing is a whole other
thing.
The thing man.
And when you get these seven footers
that can kick ass like volkov,
that's a fucking nightmare.
What does he like?
He's at least six.
11,
right?
Scary.
He sees a big guys bigger than,
than redoing by a lot.
So call it six,
six,
seven,
somewhere in that range.
Right?
For dumas,
let six,
four.
Somewhere around that.
And when we ever met brett rogers,
who's brett?
Roger,
roger,
and now brett rogers fought a grim
rogers.
Yeah.
That guy.
That's the biggest person I've ever.
Really.
Yeah,
like I don't know what it was about his
frame,
but I was trying to interview and it's
only six,
nine or six,
eight or something.
But it was the physical frame of him and
I was just like,
it was so wild.
A triple h and a restaurant one time.
And I was like,
whoa.
Like giant dude.
He's,
he's big,
big athletes like this.
Like what?
The force that they can generate like in
god and that ability to,
to create that type of power and impact.
This is a crazy
picture of in Ghana standing next to a
professional basketball player and a god
who looks like a tiny person.
So weird.
It god who looks like I look what I
stand next to him.
Not quite as much contrast but pretty
ridiculous,
but there it is.
Look at that.
it's fucking crazy.
We just,
there's,
there's more always,
but I have a chihuahua.
Have a chihuahua and you have your dog.
Put them beside each other and you're
like,
that can't be the same species.
I know.
It's weird.
Right?
Then humans are just like dogs in that
way.
You know,
we vary.
so wildly size.
No,
he listened to it.
Let's wrap this up.
Um,
tell people where they can get your
breakdowns,
mma stuff.
If you're from dublin,
Ireland.
I'm there doing my one man show.
June 22nd.
How often do you do in this?
I'm doing this will be the fifth I
think.
And there was one practice,
one sort of friends and family.
I learned a lot from it then winnipeg
than london,
ontario and I did because I knew
harmonic and now I've got some good
friends there that would be supportive
and that was good.
Then I sold out a little venue in
toronto and went really,
really well,
and then now Ireland,
so the 22nd in I'm in Ireland on my
instagram page you can click through,
but and john kevin was going to be my
guest.
Beautiful website.
It's coming up.
It literally could be coming up today or
in the next couple of days.
I think it's robin black mma.com
and robin black mma on twitter and
instagram and if you follow me on
instagram,
I set out to do 100 breakdowns in three
months and I've done 118 10.
That's how you try to develop mastery.
You just got to be prolific and develop
a great following.
You know,
it's awesome.
Appreciate you brooks brothers.
Let's do a scan please.
Robin black ladies and gentlemen.